two hello everybody it is Wednesday it
is August 16th it is a beautiful sunny
day out here in Los Angeles
see your heart up Streamys
today's episode is sponsored by
expressvpn thank you to our sponsors who
we love love love love
good job
it's about 110 degrees of this room
is
wow and as you can see
xqc will be uploading that later to his
uh YouTube channel
yeah that's fair use thank you guys well
done through Zach and Ian of course the
collaboration of the of a lifetime the
role of a lifetime
how's everybody doing today we've got a
fun show here any thoughts and prayers
in the peanuts gallery
just looking forward to eating some
toilet food man so here we go today
Samantha as I like to call her
is a Chef Boyardee she's a chef
extraordinaire
and she had oh
some new kind of Vibes I like them
and Sam is taking a challenge upon
herself
on Tick Tock there's a dude who cooks
all of his meals in hotel rooms I'm
talking about slow cooking ribs
talking about
with the uh
iron
and so Sam got inspired so if we we can
cut to Sam just say hi real fast so
she's gonna be in the bathroom today
cook cooking us a full course Chef's
menu
a prefix menu
and we'll be trying it straight out of
the toilet bowl
uh as we wait
for that thank you Zach
hmm
but yeah we're gonna review some of our
favorites
and then uh I think it's gonna be
delicious I think Sam is gonna
oh I know it's a major movie yeah yeah
it's gonna be it's gonna be the idea of
it that scares me that is gonna be
physically beautiful
um everyone's saying I look super young
oh thank you here's Sam California poopy
kitchen I heard Dan used to work there
hello it looks like you're in prison Sam
I feel like it the volume's a little
quiet you know I've have you seen those
tick tocks where people cook in prison
yeah it's giving that like the in the
bags and with little hats Kool-Aid packs
they use for lipstick so gnarly
all right yeah right go ahead Sam yeah
I'm working on uh this is what I call
the pooved so I'm using the back of the
toilet as a sous-vide tank and actually
I've got my steaks
to filet mignon oh
I'm ready to drop them in so let's get
it Leah let's just get it started now
yeah I'm gonna go ahead and just drop
these in because they're gonna cook for
about 40 to 50 minutes okay thickness so
there's that then and then inside the
vacuum seal Sam is there some kind of
herbs or Oils what's going on inside yes
the fat is rolled in brisket seasoning
and I put some seasoning salt on the
rest fantastic and okay so after that
I'm going to use the burner of the
coffee pot to give it a nice sear oh I'm
also going to use the coffee pot to cook
my instant mashed potatoes can I ask you
are you afraid that there's any shot
that the coffee pot shatters no over the
steaks I'm not I'm not worried about
that okay it's gonna be good and then
I'm going to steam some green beans in
here and add a garlic butter sauce that
looks to be a kettle it is it is an
electric kettle and then I'm gonna cook
some bacon with my straightener yeah
oh this sounds like a good ass meal Sam
is in the laboratory aka the bathroom
that's what I always call the bathroom
anyway
so yeah this is uh this is the setup
so here it is prison cooking with Sam we
love it we love it very exciting I'm
excited to bring you a gourmet meal now
Sam
the toilet water is at a cool 140
degrees if I were to take a dump in
there with my poop cook yes it would it
would be fall off the bone
wow
sorry to be so graphic but what would
that smell like
I mean probably not good put a little
chives a little butter uh when
you're done you know when you're done
leave it at hot let's see if we can do
some experience we got hot hot
baby so there it is so much to look
forward to
uh thank you Sam we'll continue to check
in with her throughout the episode
I'll keep you posted thank you Sam there
it is
so um
that's very exciting hey there's a new
sound of me trending on Tick Tock I was
trying to click this last night and it
kept taking me to random
Tick Tock videos so I wasn't able to
actually see it hopefully it works on
the laptop okay here it is true that's
really really really okay wow 730 000
likes okay let's see
if that's true that's really really
really horrible I do genuinely believe
that's true based on nothing
okay
I don't even remember that okay now how
long before like uh
Ross starts posting this about their low
low prices or something their sale is
almost over
I so let's see how do I go to the sound
page so you click below uh follow
original sound
there oh here it is yeah
so we're at this moment we're only at 2
400 unlike you know my mega viral moment
I had was at a hundred thousand uses so
we're gonna have to hopefully keep an
eye on this if that's true that's really
really really I mean who I cast probably
also have a problem with women only
believe that's true based on nothing if
that's true that's really really that's
funny I personally don't like cats
based on nothing if I'm fine with cats
we're chill with each other but I think
if I had a cat I'd love them I take that
Ian no editorial additions please
[Music]
men who hate Barbie movie probably hate
women that I believe was horrible I do
genuinely believe that's true based on
nothing that I believe not a groomer I'm
just a loser
if that's true that's really really when
someone out really hates cats I believe
that's true basically I better change my
tune on cats because I'm gonna be taking
anything I've ever grown yeah another
cat one okay the cat the cat memes are
out here powerful so that's exciting to
keep our eyes uh open for I'm here live
target Walmart if you're looking for a
new uh sound on Tick Tock go ahead
you'll definitely be hearing from my
lawyer
that's right I'm getting rich on these
Tick Tock sounds that's really really
really 12 year old May convinced that
Naruto was going to come save me from an
abusive household oh that's dark Jesus I
do genuinely believe that's true based
on nothing I hope Naruto saves you girl
I'm rooting for you
okay great
also just to touch on a story we talked
about on Wednesday or Monday sorry the
Bobby vs Drake drama
so Bobby posted potentially a clue
about if this was a
was this a stunt or was this a genuine
following up big announcement coming
next Wednesday set a reminder you guys
will not want to miss this 9 A.M next
Monday
is she and we we suspect that this has
something to do with Drake
I mean this could it could explain this
weird falling out if it doesn't if this
has nothing to do with Drake then there
was a real falling out between them
that's my opinion foreign
you don't believe you don't you don't
necessarily believe this do you Dan
well I just I I mean I see why you can
infer that but
I don't know I I believe it it's so
vague that it could just end up being
nothing related to that there's a lot of
thoughts though in the comments and
responses to this story a lot of people
are like yeah Drake is a petty of
course he would do this
I saw some people saying Drake wanted
the money
which to me seems less like and he's so
rich why wouldn't he want her to yeah no
that what does that I don't know a lot
of people were saying that which didn't
make a lot of sense he wants the money
from the YouTube Revenue apparently
that's what people thought genuinely it
doesn't make any sense yeah it's
probably being paid like 50 million
dollars to just post Instagram stories
about steak I don't think he needs he's
like girl you need to send me that two
thousand dollars right now yeah
uh another theory was just something
about with the label
you know on it was an unauthorized
interview maybe he needs to get I don't
know but we'll find out on Monday I'll
be able to say one for one one way or
the other
if this was a falling out or a publicity
stunt
Thank You Drake
Jason Nash by the way friend of the show
not really sure
how is he a friend of the show I don't
know he's not really easy not at all is
he an enemy of the show I don't know
kind of I mean what he did yesterday was
kind of crazy you're talking about what
that was Colleen Ballinger thing yeah
let's see if he's the so here's Jason
apparently on stage yeah let's not
forget what he did to poor young Seth oh
obvious oh my God I totally forgot that
was Jason Nash
um
here he is on stage defending Colleen
Ballinger
an interesting take from Jason and you
know he's he's not he's not afraid to go
against thought the crowd refreshing
take yeah yeah let's see all right Jason
negativity almost or something
it seems like you whether it's Trisha
attacking you over and over and again
right you just you're not responding or
it doesn't seem maybe it does affect you
behind the scenes that we don't I know
this guy no offense to him it's really
weird he he's emailed me a bunch of
times and he gets these huge interviews
but when you go to his channel nobody
watch it and he I think he he like are
you sure he's not big on Facebook or
something that's like always the Dark
Horse it really is so tell me tell me do
some Ops on this wait what's his name
does anybody know this guy's name no
I've never seen him so he's this is a
whole conspiracy he he says like yo I'm
part of like um
says he's Part Of Fortune or some
reputable magazine but it doesn't seem
like he works for them anymore and he
posted to his personal YouTube channel
has he been was this like years ago that
he was like always emailing you he's
still doing it oh and he gets like a
thousand remember this guy and um he
seems like a nice guy a fine guy it's
just it's an interesting operation he's
got going there
um but nobody knows who he is
yeah I mean he's even emailed me and I
don't know who he is oh he emailed you
trying to get me what about you Dan
you'd be a good guy Tom Ward is that it
that sounds right that sounds right
somebody in the chat just said Tom Ward
okay so you do know yeah
okay so is this guy have a face he only
has a 39 000 subs and then look look at
the guests he has nothing Ward show
oh my God
39th the Jason Nash interview has 235
views
[Laughter]
hold on I'm going to I'm going wait what
235 let me send it how did people even
find that to post it on our subreddit
yeah that's it is
so somehow this guy is interviewed like
look these are all people he's
interviewed right Jake Paul
garyvee wait hold on oh
I I'm only talking about this not to be
mean just because it's so
odd and it's so interesting I've been
fascinated by this guy
the Tom Ward show so is he an industry
plan oh um I don't think so he's the
opposite of an industry plan this guy's
been trying to do this for years and
he's gonna have 100 views wait is he on
Facebook I'm looking right now Facebook
is the worst social media website though
and everything I'm just getting constant
pop-ups
so look who he's done interviews for
David dubrick
[Music]
he had an exclusive interview with Logan
Paul four years ago only got 170 views
Natalie Noel Charlie demilio wait this
can't really be him can it the Tom Ward
show on Facebook has 10 followers
I'm telling you I don't know what's
going on with him he has hundreds that
has to be the wrong no that is his
account what the that's him bro
what's this who be what the who
be this is just his link tree of all
this stuff there oh so this is an of His
official name yeah so let's let's check
everything and not again not to be rude
it's just a fascinating weird thing
so we got where's his audience maybe
it's purely the on the audio side Google
uh look his name up in the email because
he pitches it in a way where I saw it I
was like oh this sounds like it could be
interesting but then I I do some Ops
right I'm curious who it is which
apparently some people don't yeah and I
go to his channel and it's got like 100
views and I mean listen I mean no
offense I'm not I'm down to talk to
anyone but he has a 43 ratings on
Spotify
there it is
he's a big fan
he says read it
I'm a big fan I would love to do an
interview with Ethan this is from 2019
by the way this is an old ass email we
do the Forbes article and Forbes I film
it for my YouTube channel so he I don't
even think he works for Forbes anymore
like type his name Forbes and see if he
isn't even active uh he yeah he is a
thousand on Tick Tock there he is what's
his latest he's a contributor uh June
5th not that long ago he is so so so
like why are you not
I think people are doing this under the
assumption that there's yes an
affiliation with Forbes but there isn't
so there's Ridiculousness right here
right for Forbes but
is this so weird well a lot of people
can write on Forbes but they're not
getting published to the actual news
page they're unlisted basis yeah a lot
of people it's like an opinion page but
yeah your opinions expressed by Forbes
contributors are their own so it's not
he's not like he's not even a pace he
does not get like put on the front page
ever it's just a fact am I this is so
weird right very strange Instagram a
thousand Tick Tock a thousand and again
once again to go back to his guests
[Music]
um Paris Hilton
wait Stasi Schroeder wait wait is that
the girl from
oh my God yeah that's the girl that's
stassi from vanderplump I hate that I
know this she looks so different Ila
infected Ally with an obsession with
Vanderpump and it's all I've been
hearing in our apartment for dude he got
Stasi Schroeder Stussy
um going down the line you know garyvee
apparently was on here although I can't
find him anywhere different
three thousand
I was in
everybody looking for Paris Hilton 4 000
views garyvee is only six it's only 16
minutes long okay fine 4 000 views what
the why is it so short
okay let's see no offense Tom I'm just
curious
I I
like does he have a big audience what I
see a lot of people doing which is they
give information and then they want to
charge you for that information shut up
Gary you're annoying Gary you
idiot dumbass
this is a big thing in like the SEO
World they sell Forbes blogs and he's
basically selling four blogs for
interviews
it's like a thousand bucks to buy it
usually oh and you get a link from
Forbes to your website and like
that I'm pretty sure I saw Emma
Chamberlain on here too but maybe she
had him remove it because it's just kind
of embarrassing look at this this dude
from uh
uh Pimp My Ride 600 views
he's a good dude
Charlotte Emilio Charlie DeMille has
been on like 5K that one actually got a
little bit of views garyvee I mean what
the is going on here you know yeah
and you would think not to be rude Tom
but I just don't think it's gonna happen
because like you you somehow tricked all
these people to coming on and it's still
Ryan or Jason Nash is only getting 200
views
how's that even possible
[Laughter]
let's get let's watch and see if we can
get a sense for
why is this interview so not good the
most successful people in the world
teach you how to elevate your life you
wanted me to come on your show and tell
people how to elevate their life
because I would that's not what I that's
not that's not Ethan that's not what I
do you want advice on like ruining your
life yeah I mean reputation well
here you brought uh Jason National to
ruin his life and defend Colleen
Ballinger let's take a look at that
you know
oh yeah so there was an Emma Chamberlain
interview I knew it look at this
I think she must have got him to erase
it or some
and and I don't blame her
he says my Forbes interview with Emma
Chamberlain
okay see if this is actually on Forbes
Google that in 2018.
you know orbs Tom
wardrobe Instagram is like you know
whatever like she's like changing and
all the and I was like yo you can
just roll the back who is that I
don't even know it's actually so funny
you click on it you should send me a
okay probably like let's do the Forbes
43 questions okay don't sleep on YouTube
Star Emma Chamberlain
so he's doing this weird thing he's like
look what I did for Emma
it's not wait there's no video
there's no video
I still don't think this is like an
actual Forbes article this is just like
a Blog because forces the Vlog pretty
much yeah it's just it has a there's two
sides of Forbes because look at this it
goes Forbes leadership CMO Network the
the exact same as his other
articles
could have been like he's like do you
mind if I record the interview
that and then he puts it on his personal
YouTube channel
where it gets 100 views
and then she has to request her PR team
that tell him to erase it this is crazy
this is like I see these scams on scams
on Fiverr where people do this they sell
these I don't think I don't know he
wasn't trying to charge me well he
charges no I have an interview I think
he's Earnest in wanting to like build up
a podcast and everything no I think he
yeah Amy he I'm not going to say that he
wasn't trying to get money from me no
I'm saying you paying is your exposure
for his podcast who's paying no one is
paying but instead of paying you're
giving him exposure being on his podcast
that's what I mean so instead of a paid
exchange he posted on his 10 person blog
yeah that's what I mean the thing is he
I don't know how he's done this is so
weird I'm so it's so funny that this guy
came up I've always wondered about him
Tom Ward you said yourself your his
email almost got you you were interested
yeah because like oh Forbes wants to
interview me and then I was like wait
what the is this this is Tom Ward
not Forbes
you know so let's see what Jason Nash
had to say on the Tom Ward
the only thing warding off is the
viewers
Tom warding off the viewers
but this dude's been at it for four
years he's gotten super famous people
and nobody's watching this I'm sorry Tom
it's just time to move on someone said
PNP tactic just turn the camera on and
start asking all right let's see
what Tom got out of Jason the negativity
almost or something it seems like you
you also I feel like he's too uh sorry
again Tom he's too old because he's like
talking to Emma Chamberlain 17 year old
Emmett Chamberlain like like I am
fascinated by everything in your life
it's like
cool
unlike me of course how old is Tom Ward
before I accuse him of being done I was
just looking it up go on
uh I don't know man
he's got to be pushing 50 that time his
age there's a more famous Tom Ward so we
can't even find his age man
he's got merch
well the other Tom Ward is 52. so
um he's got to be around that age
the British film star
although somebody did find this and
posted to our subreddit so I guess the
negativity almost or something it seems
like you whether it's Trisha attacking
you over and over and again right you
just you're not responding or it doesn't
seem maybe it does affect you behind the
scenes that we don't dude look at how
over this he is I've never
seen an unhappier looking person look at
it oh my God
he's like is this what am I doing here
is this Forbes where's my article
see or with the Jeff stuff you know all
that went on like how do you stay I
guess positive and out of all the
trappings the drum that comes along with
this I learned I learned like a long
time ago that like you can't
I can't win it that game so if you if
you feed into any of that
it's just gonna
bite you in the end and
um
so for the people that like do drama I
mean that's the dude that's the duplex
strategy it eventually I found the
opposite to be true frankly like when
keemstar was lying about me for all
those years and people were just like
turning on me I tried to ignore it
and it starts to snowball to the point
where people will believe and say
anything about you and when I started
addressing it is when it started to
clear up
this is the dubrick strategy and I think
the problem with Jason and the duber
crowd is that the things they've done
are so heinous and that they've actually
done them
that accepting responsibility for them
means being sued into Oblivion or
potentially even arrested
so I guess it's a little bit harder for
them to not feed into it but it comes
first so
um and you've got to be built for that
you've got to be able to be like yeah I
don't care I'm building I don't
necessarily know if I'm built for that
yeah yeah like I'm not built for like uh
oh he said this and you hear that Ryan
Kavanaugh you I'm built for this
you clown
look at that and it's just like who
gives a you know like honestly who
get like who gives off like Colleen
Ballinger like oh my God I don't care no
no no no you're not about to co-sign him
are you Tom
no no no don't speak on something you
don't know about now Jason Tom wait
Tom's about to back him up
I'm worried Tom you bet you've spent
someone building this this perfect
career don't you dare don't throw it all
away somewhere now
don't here it is I you know the girl's
been on YouTube for 20 years she maybe
she made some missteps but you know like
dumb you why would you say that
Jason why would you call sending porn to
a minor a misstep well just like
wondering listen In dubrick's Crowd it
is a mystery that's true that's true it
is baby I mean you know pranking
dude into
I can't even summarize what he did to
Seth without sounding like crazy oh but
yeah that that was a misstep too yes I'm
gonna sit there and and
drag her and make money off her or her
name like I think it's really low yeah I
think it's really really freaking low
and I won't do it like I won't you're so
much better than me Jason
you're so much better than me
God
so above everything
that's what I love about Jason Nash he's
except well the one thing he is under of
course is David's thumb
toe foot not as much anymore does he
I don't know I don't know what goes on
in David yeah I don't know
I'll I'll literally go work at
Fuddruckers or Starbucks before I
that's literally not true you have
debased yourself to the utmost level in
order to keep dilbrick's money coming
from
you would do anything before working at
Fuddruckers trust me
[Music]
it just won't do it and it's
um
and so you see the bags under his eyes
man that's a man who's seen
no offense again to Jason but those are
some bags those bags those bags
they've got those suitcases have luggage
what does it say you've got uh
my brain don't work so good
he's got baggage
under his eyes
I want to see what Tom said about it
I love Tom Ward he's my absolute fave so
I'm reading into his history and it
seems like his big break was an article
with Jake Paul and then after writing
this Forbes article for Jake and Jake
sharing it then Jake was able to hook
him up with interviews with like Emma
Chamberlain and these other big people
like Josh Richards David dobrik
so I'm guessing that's what he's doing
he's just doing but it's not oh man Tom
You Had Your Shot it's just not
happening oh man
I don't know am I being too mean to Tom
I mean he's just working he's out there
Tom's doing his thing I do feel like he
tried to mislead me a little bit with
his Forbes Association
well I so when you brought this up and
you mentioned that he used to email you
a lot like I said it immediately rang a
bell
um and Lena who acts has access to your
your like public work email uh-oh
searched his name and there's several
exchanges there are several emails that
he sent but this one caught Lina's eye
wait and I remember this happening now
this was so funny wait wait wait
this is an exchange I had with Tom not
with Tom with uh with his Booker Tom has
a Booker it says Steve Ross yeah
probably Steve Ross well I censored the
name because I actually based it might
be a real person but here um do you
remember getting this email hey team H3
it's blank I'm the talent Booker for the
Tom Ward podcast and he would love to
have Ethan on the show
I loved working with Timothy at full
screen on his podcast I have no idea
what that means but we can tape when and
where it's convenient for him
do you remember this now yes I remember
we were like so confused we were like
why it's bolded holy I remember
being like who is this guy okay
right right right right okay this is why
I have a irrational distaste for Tom
Ward nice finally wait hold that back up
again
oh sorry let me let me read it verbatim
for the audio listeners
uh oh
Tom's book or Steve Rossi reached out to
us
yeah should I interview Tom do a little
switch the tables on him gorilla's ass
so what were you trying to uh pull up
the email again
your part or the whole thing the whole
thing I okay or my part should I send it
with the time stamps too
words
cut out I didn't save it but also that
wasn't the first one the first time he
he read personally
we should send Jimmy when was the last
time you reached out to me
the messages that Dan is showing you now
that looks like the last conversation
he gave up oh check there's some good
details later here let me see if I have
my personal
this is uh after the where it's
convenient for him we have a studio
booked for this Thursday evening
uh he's interviewed everyone from Demi
Lovato friend of the show Kate Hudson
David dobrik friend of the show Shane
Dawson front of the show
[Music]
now launching new podcasts so this was
early on you were one of the original
guests here here's his real here is his
articles on Forbes
thank you for your consideration so yeah
I was I was
flabbergasted he says we can tape when
and where it's convenient for him
bold all caps pull that back up again
it seems like a threat I know what are
you threatening me yeah
we have a studio book this Thursday it's
like it's Thursday
it's Thursday at our studio no other
options available show up or else
did he strong-arm all these people
[Music]
and then I responded he sounds like a
busy guy it sounds like a busy guy
I wasn't sure what the they're
making did they reply to that did they
respond they did they said uh uh only if
you keep him busy interviewing awesome
people like you smiley face wow I guess
she's a nice retort yeah she didn't get
it yeah
I have never been propositioned like
that in my life and by the biggest
nobody too
like listen I've you know like
it's also weird that part of me still
feels like he secretly has a massive fan
base on like on Rumble
not on Facebook on Tumblr yeah he's huge
on Tumblr
if it's not on YouTube
it could be on Snapchat I don't know
he's a LinkedIn influencer
they are addressing the H3 podcast and
talking about you Ethan who Tom is Tom
live right now
they're saying because the email was to
the H3 podcast the hymn was in reference
to you not wait hold on pull that up
dude no way it was in reference to you
no I I I I I get that it was but the
wording is still hilarious wait
they're talking about it it's addressed
to hey team h3h3 it's
been on the show we can tape it whenever
it's convenient for him but the thing is
is that
they mentioned pull up the whole email
okay got it I have to read it again yeah
it's definitely yeah the whole email I
still think it's funny to write him yeah
no it's yeah what the was that but
then to make it even more confusing
they're like we have a studio on
Thursday yeah like this dude doesn't
have a studio right we got it ready only
for Thursday
and it sounds important and like if
you're not there something they're gonna
lose something big they're like we have
the studio it's in place you've got to
be there in bold okay it says I'm a
talent Booker for the Tom Ward show
we can tape when it's convenient for him
but and he would love to have Ethan on
this show we can take when and where
convenient for him the hymn is this are
you sure yeah yeah that's definitely the
intent because it's crazy otherwise but
I but it obviously I understand why you
I mean I interpreted that way too like
it seems like then we have a studio book
Thursday even yeah
okay maybe I maybe also maybe this is
part of why your show's not popping off
Tom I mean even your emails are
confusing right I thought you were
insulting me
all trajectory of Tom's career if you
had just read this email a little more
carefully you know we got him I think
they they bowled those parts because
this is a generic email so they swap it
and they want to make sure that they
swapped it so Ethan then him yeah
just blast this out oh here I can draw
your attention to it
yeah it's big news that's big news oh
boy that's great
well shout out Tom Ward
shout out my boy my good old boy
he's grinding hard I gotta he's grinding
he's been grinding for years he's got
some respect on us he's grinding to the
Bone man he's hustling he's got nothing
left no way look at this exclusive wow
bro
how many views did the Joe Biden
interview have Joe is looking at like
400 400 views for the president what's
happening to his skull come on
come on Jack making fun of old man's
shape shame on you
you get down dude pull Chuck pull
up push up right now that that that that
that that that
[Music]
this man has not had an interview with
Oh look The
what the four weeks ago what he had
his biggest video with nine thousand
with Alex or Mosey
these all have like 90 views
that's how much you get like that's like
how much watch when you post it to your
family on Facebook yeah
man
here's the truth I failed this year
he's the founder of rude the streetwear
brand that's been worn by everyone from
Jay-Z to LeBron James and he said
something that really stuck with me and
I'm still thinking about is this this is
1080.
the people need to learn to lean into
their struggles and share those because
it's not 1080 it doesn't look 1080.
it feels like to win but everyone knows
what it feels like what are these cats
that really resonated with me because
I'm thinking like all of us of sharing
our wins look at me on social look at me
on Instagram or on Tick Tock hey I'm at
Paris Hilton's house hey look at me I'm
a David dobrik's house hey I'm at the
rude fashion show isn't this cool look
at me what I don't show you is kind of
what's going on behind the scenes and
really I'm failing a lot of you don't
that's that's in front of the scenes
hold on Tom I don't want to be again I'm
not trying to be mean to my my dear
friend Tom but the feeling is in the
front and in the back
I'm team Tom after that I mean it's
funny hold on let me lie let me know
this but I quit my steady job that I had
for 10 years no selling kitchen
equipment to grocery stores no oh I like
this guy
come on
that's me if you never hired me this the
last thing this guy need is a yes man
can I bring him on he's trying man
reach out to his uh booking AJ and tell
him when it's convenient for me
he could come on
this guy's gonna get the stream he's
next year Tom Ward podcast baby
alive last year and focus on YouTube
full time well if you look at some of my
previous videos just go back and look
I'm failing My Views suck okay okay fair
fair you're a good guy you're a good man
yeah he's a good man Rob Dyrdek a couple
weeks ago that's a good example of it
and if you look it cost me two thousand
dollars to shoot and edit the video
father of God bro you did you
interviewed Rob Dyrdek and you got
200 views
but how we have to do something but how
was it look again okay I'm starting to
respect the hustle and so I'm not trying
to be just real quick how is it possible
to fail that hard
like I don't need I didn't know it was
possible it's the algorithm dude the
algorithm yeah unless you started this
channel by on his homies like
blippi then I don't understand how the
algorithm well apparently that juice is
the algorithm yeah
I feel for this guy man I gotta I gotta
wonder what's going on killing My Views
suck I interviewed Rob Dyrdek a couple
weeks ago that's a good example of it
and if you look it cost me two thousand
dollars to shoot and edit the video plus
all the time prepping for it getting
there coming back reviewing it making
notes all that and it hasn't even
cracked 300 views so how how
Tom Dyrdek's a big deal
robbed are we sure it's actually Rob
Dyrdek it's not like a fake Ellen
situation it's Robert Van Dyke I mean
I'll look just to make sure but all
these other people are real celebrities
you just said Jason Nash on it couldn't
crack 302. if something happened it's
like some good ass deep fake or some
let's let's see I'll go back
someone put a curse on him okay
man yeah I know he's trying I'm just
trying to analyze it's fascinating you
can't deny it's fascinating oh without a
doubt I just want to know how the
he gets these big names that's it
because he because his emails the Forbes
emails
people no he's magnetic
it's the YouTube game is different I
mean even how he was talking about that
you know about like uh that's the game
like he learned so much from the episode
with you maybe it's just YouTube
yeah but well okay first of all how we
first of all wasn't getting 300 reviews
the second of all I could point
to a lot of things Howie was doing wrong
right with Tom I don't understand why is
he failing so hard
he's interviewing famous people I mean
what more is there this should blow up
on Tick Tock like if you have Jason Nash
I feel like you'd get a couple thousand
but these only have five likes each how
is that possible that even on Tick Tock
like Tick Tock is the easiest platform
to get tons of users yeah especially big
names he's a he's the cooler if I bring
him on our show nobody's everybody's
gonna stop watching yeah somewhere it
might be uh anti-balled bigotry oh I did
not say anything about his beautiful
dough but I'm just saying that's an
explanation I mean this guy is grinding
his ass off he's got big names nobody's
watching because he's a baldy
that's an interesting Theory it's a good
theory well let's see what he asked Rob
whatever the laptop guy Enterprises our
money's Fearless right and the concept
was scared money doesn't make money so
our money
Studio like uh you know pretty good
lighting and everything it's Moody but
he shouldn't be laughing he should be
listening intently
if I can give him some because what he's
saying is not funny it's it's you know I
used to say
this is the
it's a Jimmy Fallon method right he's
like oh do I hear your dog bad
spending too much time with dobrik this
is the ridiculous guy I have some
respect Rick Enterprises our money's
Fearless right and the concept was
scared money doesn't make money so our
money's fearless and it was so like he's
even got like the good ass water what is
this one Fuji
that's expensive man that's expensive
Out of Water Fiji you're incredible
um I'm loving this Tom word stuff oh we
really got to do our ad and we need to
check in with Sam
so let me watch one minute of this
okay it should have been deer deck
Enterprises our money is just dumb I'm
Tom Warden over the place they
misspelled his name in the title they
did yeah Rob dyrick yeah wait seriously
yeah it's
d-y-r-d-e-k only misspelled it
oh you're right wait ah maybe that's why
wait that's probably why wait after
everything you've done you still
misspelled it you were just talking
about how you went through
you went through so much you misspelled
the name man
it's misspelled Tom uh Poor Tom man can
we do something for him
I'm team Tom too man I can't spell
either I'm team Thomas
[Laughter]
check in the title
I didn't make it this far by not still
checking
sit down with some of the biggest
celebrities and influencers in the world
what I've always found Most Fascinating
is the stories of the businesses that
they've built behind the scenes on this
show you'll get an inside look of what
it takes to build a successful business
from some of the biggest celebrities
not becoming entrepreneurs in the world
this is the time I'm here for Rob
welcome to the Tom Ward show it's time
to level up we're sitting here with the
legend Rob Deer deck we got a coach Tom
yeah we can make it happen I want to
make some clips for him on tick tock
the beginning of his party hey guys it's
time to level up welcome to my pod
it's time to level up we gotta get rid
of the level up thing it's not working
right I mean look I think we let's look
at Howie Mandel's podcast as a case
study
I think we
basically Rob we made Howie Mandel to be
honest
[Music]
oh no my live doesn't show here
I love Howie this is so awesome
oh here he is doing a Rob Howie Mandel
welcome next to our new podcast
so how many views did Rob get on how is
because I know Rob did his too let's see
Rob Robbie boy
Robbie
Robbie boy
I can't find it
all right so let's do the sponsor uh
yeah we'll move on
huh 86k okay all right thank you Tom uh
Reach Out Tom send me another email
we'll we'll link up and do something I'm
sorry that was the second time first
time 36k God bless uh oh two okay so you
want to check in with Sam or should I do
the ad first
all right let's let's check in with
Samantha
we have uh some updates from the
bathroom
um
is she
are the stakes ready is the bacon bead
flat ironed
I'm about to take the stakes out they
have 60 seconds
I am getting started on the sides right
now I'm about to start cooking the green
beans oh we gotta see that wow
we're having some technical issues in
the bathroom Sam what is it like cooking
in the toilet like do you feel like
eating about it or no honestly like I
would do this again okay I think it's
fine like it's it's it's vacuum sealed
so like I'm not I'm not worried I'm glad
that no one saw uh what got like
um kicked up from the bottom of the tank
chicken from London just seasoning
it's a little something there's nothing
to worry about it's just on Old all
right Dan is back there with the camera
how we doing Dan there's here we are we
got the feed Sam is there with what
looks like some green beans yummy
okay I'm going to go ahead and put the
green beans
into the electric kettle
and I'm going to steam these
for I don't know like six minutes or so
and are you are you uh seasoning the
green beans or is it just a straight I'm
gonna season them afterwards okay
fantastic
all right here it is oh that's going
that's fantastic that of course that
will work yeah of course and then
here I'm going to pour two cups of water
into the Basin of the coffee maker this
one I'm more confused about the
logistics of
nah
Sam is heating up a coffee maker and
then she's gonna be cooking Idaho mashed
potatoes
we love Idaho so the master okay I see
what's happening the mattress go in the
coffee
pot
and you're just gonna be brewing coffee
like normal into the instant mashed
potato yes I like my coffee dark and I'm
gonna mix some butter and cream
when they're done and I'm going to add
sour cream on top with bacon and chives
they're going to be like loaded mashed
potatoes and where are you making the
butter sauce
um
I don't know yet I haven't thought that
far okay actually I'm gonna use this uh
the warming plate under the coffee pot
as sort of a uh burner oh my God that's
exciting timer my timer just went off
for the steak so exciting if you want to
accompany me this way to the oven
here come the sous-vide perfectly
cooked steaks
wow
he's dipping in the tongs into the
toilet bowl and here wow that looks like
Perfection here comes another one may
that looks good good good so
I'm gonna sear these so they'll get a
little more color on the top but for a
sous-vide steak I think that that's
pretty good color for uh
absolutely what and so I'm excited to
watch you uh saute those on the coffee
pot that I want to see that
you'll have to come back because I'm
cooking the potatoes right now all right
so I don't want to show the potatoes is
the water filtering in there
it's get it's getting started the water
has to heat up yeah starting to Dripping
all right so here let's go thank our one
sponsor and we'll come back check up uh
maybe you know talk about something
other things we've got lots of other
stuff to get to thank you Sam I'm I'm
getting hungry
for some bathroom food right there bye
all right thank you to our sponsor we
got one here and I'm so grateful to
expressvpn
man
using the internet without expressvpn is
like checking in your baggage at the
airport without a lock
you think your stuff is being kept
private but you never know who's going
through your panties your hemorrhoid
creams
you're
vibrators
butt plugs
also in my case I always travel with the
uh
the dildo that you strapped to your
forehead
[Music]
you know what I'm talking about Dan
no no
you ever wonder why I'm so good at this
oh
nobody I get it
all right I wondered why does everyone
need a VPN you ask when you go online
without a VPN internet service providers
can see every single website you visit
they can sell this information legally
without your consent to add companies
and Tech Giants who then use your data
to Target you I don't need any more
digital profiles with myself
okay
I don't need my Alexa listening and then
trying to send me you know
ads for hemorrhoid cream frankly
although maybe I need the hemorrhoid
cream maybe that is good
yeah you've been talking about hammeriz
a lot you good
no actually I don't need him okay my my
b-hole is doing fine
the one thing on my body that seems to
be doing fine that's nice we have health
updates for you guys too
um
browse more anonymously when you use
expressvpn isps cannot see your online
activity your identity is an anonymized
by secure VPN server and your data is
also encrypted for maximum protection
it's easy to use fire it up
click the app you don't have to think
about it dude click one button your
Bob's your uncle you're good to go works
on all devices too phones laptops
routers
you do it on the router everyone who
shares your Wi-Fi is protected slick
I always talk about why I use expressvpn
for me it's the
it's getting into that good content in
other countries you can tell whatever
website you're visiting you're from any
country
so you can say hey yo I'm from England I
want to go on Netflix and watch Doctor
Who you go oh I'm from Japan I want to
go on Netflix and watch uh Miyazaki
films
you know what I mean it's awesome secure
line act secure your online activity by
visiting expressvpn.com H3 today
that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com H3 and you can get
three months for free
right now by going to expressvpn.com H3
thank you
to our wonderful sponsor please consider
supporting them
[Applause]
[Music]
Thunder's getting hyped
me too uh okay wow wow I want to talk
more about Tom Ward but I guess we
should move on I just love him we can
Circle back to it what I think we should
do is watch some of these uh prison food
tick tocks uh or bathroom tick tocks so
people actually understand why all right
that's that's do that so there's a
bathroom cooking uh meta on Tick Tock
one guy in particular is the king of it
uh Barfly 7777 that's a great name for
the guy who cooks in the toilet here he
is
cooking baby back ribs in his hotel room
and man this is impressive and also
looks kind of dangerous
don't recommend do not do this at home
right guys
could you get one of those up
[Music]
you think I shouldn't show it
no no I'm you don't you think this is
man this man's just cooking what's the
problem all right I'll play it well this
might just don't know a hotel that's
fine oh okay yeah you can burn the hotel
down yeah yeah oh yeah you're concerned
about that yes I see I thought you were
talking about like the sanitary if it
being unseen no no I don't I'm not
worried about that got it got it this
man's a trained professional this is a
trained professional he doesn't have a
hashtag private Chef that's it he's
private for himself do not do this at
home you know what I mean only if you're
a professional on that level I
understand
so here he's got a nice rack there we're
taking off the uh membrane getting blood
is his goal to be as dirty as possible
he thrashes these hotel rooms man
yeah there's blood on the wall over the
sink it probably scares the out of
the mates yeah it's going to scare
him
so let's see he's cutting it in half
he's taking a pillowcase just destroying
everything in the hotel room
he puts a it on a rack in a pillowcase
takes the
the air oh
so he's taking the air the hair blow
dryer
four hour roast
and it's just going for four hours I
mean it's just air frying basically I
guess it makes sense I didn't know that
you could that's crazy run at blow dryer
for four hours because I thought those
things were kind of dangerous because he
sucked so much power ah they do in fact
we had to bail them uh the hair dryer
portion of Sam's stuff because it was uh
way too much power holy crap I was
tripping the breaker it looks amazing
but but uh dude this man probably spent
like a hundred dollars plus in
electricity
at the hotel man he's getting his
money's worth walking right into a Best
Western and got the best meal yeah he's
gonna spend more than the hotel room
costs and
but I mean not bad right that looks good
that looks like real good
there it is
and he's even got the prison-like tray
to go with it
you gotta have them ribs you gotta have
them ribs that's right so we have
another one bathroom Fried Chicken by
the same Legend let's take a look
Fried Chicken this is Barfly
oh man
chicken go yo this guy knows what he's
doing he's butchering it
cut it up into little pieces he said
he's a private Chef maybe that's real
now he's breading it up oh he he brought
himself like a single electric fryer
yeah I mean is that that's I mean you're
just that's the intended use of that
thing yes okay so this one's a little I
mean it does look good yeah here we're
just cooking we're just Cooks that's
just standard you're just cooking with
heat man's cooking he's doing it well
looks good though damn
better than room service probably
at Best Western
uh here's another one hotel turkey let's
take a look here
what do you got for us bar fly
[Music]
Hotel turkey for under two bucks
huh wait two bucks wait what
under two dollars a serving there's a
turkey breast tenderloin
so think of Cheerios grind it up
nice making the breading out of that I
see
water and seasoned flour bucket let's go
that's clever
now he's using the raw chicken in the
ice bucket and I gotta say turkey but
yeah that's pretty insane because
they're not gonna clean that ice bucket
with the presumptions all that gross
stuff happens in the ice bucket and I
hope that he cleans everything after
this how do you clean how do you clean
raw chicken in a hotel room out of an
ice bucket yeah throw that out yeah
you guys got it I mean what the
so shout out to the family they got
salmonella after this also I'm sure like
that ice bucket has had vomit in it
before I'm sure it's been cleaned
obviously I feel like fine vomit's
easier to clean than raw chicken but the
idea of it
you're putting you're putting stuff into
it it's like us with the toilet
because I mean raw chicken is a specific
nasty Beast yeah
all right dude he's making stuffed ham
with Swiss for a turkey cordon bleu
yo that's fire that's classy it's worth
it to kill the family of first of
salmonella
for that
shoving that right in there
my man
oh God he's going in the toilet bowl so
he's going in the toilet bowl Sam no no
he was dumping out he dumped out the the
ice bucket in the toilet yeah he cleaned
it uh he poured it off yeah he's pouring
out the extra there let me see let me
see yeah
don't clog Hotel don't pour it down the
sink pour it in the toilet I didn't seem
clean this for the record that's
cleaning yeah just poured the raw
chicken juice whatever
yeah
so let's see he's got the fryer again
that probably I want to eat that badly
you want that you know what I mean yeah
look at this
oh God look at that thing juice
juicy baby that looks raw microwave the
rice they said two dollars there's no
way two dollars a serving yeah I believe
I don't believe that how well okay so
you gotta travel Cheerio that's probably
one dollar from the dollar store so half
the money already now you got ham yeah
okay and cheese 33 servings maybe you
got like a Lunchable two servings
I'm not buying I think he's eating more
than a serving though servings are known
to be very small smaller than a portion
his serving is not a portion I guess so
if he went to the Dollar Store he could
have got
the Cheerios for a dollar easy the
chairs are probably like 25 cents let's
be real one of these things are so cheap
yeah the turkey he might have got that
for a buck dude okay still though
we have
there was ham in there too right the ham
you could have got for a boss
so he's and for a buck rice yeah I get
these are all cheap ingredients I'm
still not buying the two you probably
spent five bucks on this that's fine
then say that no five splits he said per
serving Dan don't come for him he's
eating it all that's a servant give me a
break no that's a portion now
here's where I here's where I doubt him
the Crisco you can't get that cheap okay
how much is a tub of Crisco Dan's
leaving in anger
could so much look up a Christian you
can't do nothing wrong it says 6 29. see
that that's where he up
that's a premium product yeah
nice try dude depends where you are
where he is in the country too it could
be cheaper in Middle America or
something
all right go ahead we're cutting the Sam
so back to the bathroom with Sam we have
some updates here is Chef Samantha so I
just tasted a green bean they're perfect
tender tastes delicious wow so and these
are all done as well
yeah we're doubting the potatoes wow
y'all are down look at that gorgeous and
the steaks are out I do not know if that
is going to get hot enough to have any
form of a Sear
in here
so uh yeah the hot plate
well I don't have to find out yeah
so Sam is about to throw a steak on the
coffee
let me hear that sizzle
let me hear that get your microwave
oh let's go right now
she's sizzling
all right
so I'm gonna be ready to Plate this up
here soon do you want me to save the big
reveal for when I bring it out
so yeah or should I okay right yeah so
you're basically good to go is there and
what's for dessert Sam
shoe I didn't make dessert
what kind of meal is this I know
[Music]
I'm shutting this restaurant down all
right I'm excited I can't wait to try it
yeah all right I'll bring it out in just
a few minutes
well done thank you Sam for the toilet
food it looks so good absolutely well
done
yeah I'll see you soon
we'll see you soon so
um back to the
the Hotel chef the part that I'm not
loving about this is just that he did it
on a cooker
yeah it's cheating yeah I could do that
although to be fair I don't think he's
trying to invent any rules he's just
showing you how he cooks in his hotel
room
and at that point why was he doing in
the bathroom right you can do it in any
room
you're God that looks good though
he'd be eating what else is next we've
got the uh Hotel toaster chicken yum
once again from Barfly 7777
what the hell are you doing
so we got a raw chicken that's all
seasoned up
mashing it with a beer can yeah that's
awesome
it looks well seasoned how do you no
he's toasting on wait Owen baking paper
so he wrapped the chicken in baking
paper and put them in the toaster
because he flattened them real hard
this one seems like a fire hazard
this seems don't do this one I was the
one that was skeptical before don't
don't do this don't do any of this don't
do any of this people he is a trained
Chef he's a trained Chef although to be
fair Dan I I disagree that this because
I mean this is what
this parchment is meant to go in the
oven and go through extreme heat it's
fine okay it doesn't light on fire
personally I think you should have used
aluminum
that was a joke don't do that enough one
of those don't do anything here or
anything ever don't do anything do
anything ever literally don't do
anything
if I've ever influenced you to do
anything stop and don't do it just
just know it it is death don't say that
ever okay keep that to yourself never
ever ever do it
very impressive though
that looks vile
that one looks really vile I feel like
if I'd be doing this I'd use a beef only
because then you skip the salmonella
part right yeah beef is safer yeah for
sure and it doesn't need to be cooked as
hot either right
but look at that
success he didn't show himself eating
that one exactly interesting yeah I'm
not doing that
okay well here's a toilet steak uh
perhaps
the inspiration
for Samantha let's see what he did
[Music]
Barfly 7777
God oh the TV froze
what's the deal what's the deal with
that
yeah I don't know we tried swapping
everything out still happening
we have a technical issue my feed is
Frozen
[Music]
so
oh I'm back
nice
that's weird all right so here's our boy
in the bathroom let's take a look
from the beginning
looks like he will be taking the suvi
method as well
[Music]
some fingerling taters
this was the inspiration garlic I love
that man mincing garlic shrimp not sure
about that yeah
got a little now that I like is using
those little like Diner Butters because
you know he got those yeah like that
that's what I'm now he's using the
little free coffee creamers that I like
that I like
Masters to work wait we can see what the
is this I don't know but I like
what I'm seeing but how much was it we
saw
10 bucks brother oh what is 10 bucks
I told you this guy's a total fraud I
told you I've warned you all I thought
this guy was poor
nine dollars per pound cheese
raglet I never even heard of that fancy
well anyway he's putting it in the uh
Little Grill there he's gonna melt the
whole block
God damn
[Music]
not an emergency dude he's destroying
that rag we'll never live again
[Music]
okay flash sear right on the grill why
not it how's that fire alarm not go
off on that I think his smoke takes them
off before he starts
oh he's not using the whole thing
it just scraped the top of it
I'm sorry but that that looked good
[Music]
pricey though very expensive very very
crazy that one probably costs what six
dollars per serving and don't forget the
hotel I mean you got to be calculated
yeah you do have to calculate Porsches
the hotel rental
what's happening couldn't find my hat oh
fell into a The Twilight Zone
um I'm assuming he's a he's a frequent
Traveler
you know yeah yeah maybe if it's like a
business expense I can I'm fine with
calculating out of the total you know
right yeah yeah he's doing it regardless
so uh I guess Sam are you ready I'm
about to bring it out hold on just one
second
straight out I am just hold off for the
big reveal here I'm slicing the steak
and then it'll be out
um icing if we just need uh to um
bill just a minute of time here there's
a pretty big update on the Tom Ward
front I told you I want to talk more
about him I'm so excited pretty big
update on the Tom Ward front uh let me
I'm pulling it up right now stand by
I need to I need to verify this
information for myself he sent us a
cease and desist that's correct
no here it is I used to
the
Rob Deirdre interview yeah he opted the
name has been fixed yo Tom's watching
what up Tom what's up buddy we're
already giving you life-changing tips
here yeah oh yeah we love you Tom you
know you know we're in love with you Tom
we really have such a great service here
on this show of coaching creators and
turning turning it all around for them I
mean that's what we do basically and we
can do that for hourly rate for you Tom
on my that's what I do you know
whenever it's convenient for me okay
I'll let you know when that happens
interesting is Tom on Twitter is he
perhaps tweeting about us
I'll take a look I think he did have a
Twitter
Tom Ward I think it had 300 followers
I'm not even kidding dude
yeah see the first one that comes up is
a baseball player yeah
there's a lot I mean it's a fairly
common name I think you're deleted his
account yeah his link tree leads to a
bad link so oh maybe he doesn't like
Elon shout out Tom how do you do that
because he quit Twitter oh you're just
yeah right oh he does follow us there I
found him the official one yo we can Tom
your link on your link tree is broken
another tip let's fix up all this stuff
here let's go okay so Tom
he does have Twitter but he's looking to
a dentist
but he does have another 20. I'm just
saying so don't click on it don't I'm
telling you not to click on it but just
look at the Trends on the side I see
jewface what the oh that's not the
one I was pointing out that's probably
about the Bradley Cooper thing which
we're talking about oh okay in jewface
wait what's I show me
what is it he showed his chicken on
stream apparently on purpose no uh on
purpose
I don't know
I mean I know he's Young no I think he's
I show speed age
he's 18. dude that dude almost committed
child pornography yeah in a way yeah
like when he turned 18 in January so you
guys all y'all watching him got lucky by
six months you'd all be in jail
looks like he's gonna be going to kick
I'm guessing
Tom so it was on YouTube that this
happened because yeah so I I'm seeing a
bunch of memes when I'm going to Twitch
I mean to kick now let me see where he
was at well I think he was banned from
twitch I think he primarily streamed on
YouTube if I remember yeah I was on
YouTube Here's a tweet from Tom from two
hours ago I was terrified
to quit my job and try podcasting
full-time I have a mortgage a wife kids
Etc the whole deal I debated it for two
years before I finally did it I always
feared lying on my deathbed and having
regrets about things I didn't do in life
because I was too afraid so push through
that fear and try that thing that scares
you to death but you know you love it
hold on
hold on Tom give him a second like for
that I mean right I mean to the extent
that to what extent are you saying right
on
what do you mean well he is he gave up a
job
me right and he has a mortgage wife
kids the whole deal right he's been
doing it for two years how much money do
you think he's made in that two years
how much Dan I don't know I don't know
he said he debated it for two years this
was prior to quitting and becoming a
podcaster he's actually been doing the
podcast now for well I mean the first
email we got was 2018 so like five years
you know what been doing it almost as
long as us
he's a happiness billionaire
he's real he's a happiness trillionaire
that's right big moment big moment all
right we'll get back to somewhere in a
second
it smells so good that steak looks rare
girl it's not rare rare steak is the
best steak
that thick looks rare what look at that
that is the perfect it's perfect no it's
literally perfect I'd say medium rare
yeah do you like leather steak Ethan ooh
Nelly
[Music]
looks good
so here's Sam's beautiful path of
creation
you want to come stay with me love I
know you are excited to get into this
yeah sure
I'll try the green beans first
mm-hmm
oh
making interesting things so good
[Music]
I the only thing I haven't tried is
about me oh should we wait for you Dan
yeah
love bring your Michael look closer
[Music]
I don't want to ruin the presentation
what I'm gonna eat this
[Music]
steak is good
all right I'll hit this one then
hmm
wow gorgeous
try those potatoes by itself
oh yeah you like that yeah the potatoes
I get another piece of meat actually
if you don't mind this meat is gorgeous
potato there's
the green beans kicked out where's my
dude
look I'm eating nothing guys
you know
that meat hits hard and that's a good
piece I mean I'm not even kidding yeah
the meat is good the meat is the most
successful
part of this meal
yeah
I was curious yeah I'm here at this
yeah the meat is good yeah nice
seasoning peppery
[Music]
the green beans are good I think I'm
just not a fan of the instant potato Sam
oh no yeah I mean they're not great
there's not much you can do with instant
potatoes so if that's not a strike
against you at all there might there
might have been a little bit of a coffee
Essence in those potatoes as well I
liked it actually
smoke the green beans are good
the first one I had there was a little
something weird about it
but this this one's hitting what was
weird I don't know it's a garlic and
butter that's all you know
maybe the garlic
yes the garlic I think no no it was like
a bathroom thing oh oh I did not feel
that interesting you know you want to
crush this too to me all yeah I'll
finish that there's a whole ass steak to
me all all veggies taste a little bit
bathroom you know in general that's why
I don't eat them
so no one else wants this I will slam
this unironically this is a bank
oh okay well in that case well yeah but
you should definitely eat it I mean
that's a good meal right there
Ethan you got to admit your mistake for
misunderstanding Dan was right about the
two years the guy took before deciding
to become a streamer
sorry but Dan's the man in this case huh
what do I need I need to apologize shout
outs yeah
Tom that was from Tom Ward actually
no it was from Reddit gif
Tom words mom
that's delicious how many super chefs to
get Ethan to watch chiropractors
adjusting babies and toddlers yeah I did
oh yeah incredible work Sam you made
toilet it tastes so good I appreciate it
thank you Olivia yeah I think the the
toilet cook was was was phenomenal
huge success it's good
it's crazy
what are we doing everyone giving it a
shot back I'm trying the steak right now
let's see Zach I'm gonna dip it in the
pots you know
boats
good right that's busting I'd say so has
the chef right Amelia I'm not I'm about
to who ate half a piece of the steak and
put it back I ripped it with my hands
I ripped it with my hand that's the
classic Ethan movie I ripped it with my
hand I know
okay
that makes it bad
I can't believe you said that was rare
that's literally the most perfect cook
okay all right all right this year could
be better obviously you're eating a
coffee all right but
very good it's very good
Ian
Ian you better eat that you're gonna be
in trouble
finally Ian is coming to take a glorious
bike of poovie steak
here he goes Ian is on camera we love to
see you and don't we folks
[Applause]
he busted that whole damn piece in his
mouth and we love it
this man ate an entire Tsum strowman
fish
[Music]
thank you it's good
it was good it's good people
I mean listen for having been cooked in
a toilet
doesn't get much better than that girl
we gotta get our toilet put it to work
tonight I know I know I know what I'm
doing when I get home so is the is the
water still hot
yes it is so who wants to take a dump in
there
is that where the bidet water comes out
of
no no the bidet comes from a different
pipe that would be great that'd be
dangerous now do you like spicy chips
get some 140 water up that the piper
sanitize my b-hole
hey what what temperature do I need my
butthole to be at first to be safe for
consumption you don't need that you'll
need that hemorrhoid cream after that
dude
fantastic
well done Sam
very impressive very impressive
I gotta go clean my kitchen
um in short I was saying to Tom Ward
essentially like
let's just focus on dotting the eyes and
crossing the t's you know what I mean
let's get the links working let's get
the the spelling right and of your
celebrities
right but Tom I we gotta talk come
please reach out let's let's do
something
me and you
we're gonna figure this out Tommy Boy
right let me talk
the legendary Tom Ward ladies and
gentlemen
good man
somebody's uh suggestion is potentially
oh Jimmy's going to come co-interview
with me that could be a good time to
have Tom on
because because like Tom Jimmy is a man
who's basically Throwing It All Away to
live his dream wow so yeah there are
some parallels there actually
oh
all right wow
fantastic all right let's see let's go
back to the top
[Music]
wait did we ever even get to finish what
Jason was saying about Colleen
I went down the Tom hole so far we don't
really care about Jason we care about
Tommy yeah
we went so far down the Tom hole
if it was a good one and Tom you've been
prepping this hole for so long and I'm
ready I'm now ready to Journey Down it
I think it's your time Tom
he hasn't tweeted though he corrected
the spelling talk to me Tom
tell me you're out there you might be
mad
you were being maybe a little mean mad
at the beginning
it's true he might be I don't know we
don't know
this man has a family and kids dude we
gotta be exactly and he's been on the
grind for years and now he's got this
Ethan Klein I mean Tom you're not
getting the name spelled right what the
hell man you're better than that maybe
he's still at the bad part maybe he
hasn't gotten to the part where we start
being nice he right now we're just
reading emails and giggling about the
him and bold you know
all I'm saying is I love Tom I have them
for Thanksgiving dinner this year Zach
wants a Forbes article
I just I feel bad for the guy
Zach what if I did a trade where he
could come on our show but in trade he
has to do a video about Zach Lewis
that'd be sick dude I'd love
that 300 views baby I'm gonna change the
game for you it's going to number one
baby
this is I'm cooling off my head this is
a very warm bucket huh
I'm Gonna Take It Off
it's a 104 or five degrees in this room
let me just see if it make sure we heard
Jason out I think it's really low oh
yeah we did Jason was talking
um oh this is exciting Dylan page
this guy we talked about on Monday
okay who docks this poor woman
we had a tick tock blowing up yep that
was stopped dead in its track James
Charles Style video removed for
violating Community guidelines
why it just says Community guidelines
yeah no reason whatsoever they don't
usually give you any reason but was it
weird with this
the appeal when you click that button
appeal up there on the right usually you
can appeal and they come back within an
hour
they must have done something in my
opinion right I think it's too
convenient for this to just go away I
could not appeal it it said too too long
time has gone and it just happened yeah
it just happened so somebody on the back
end
theoretically right flip the switch and
said cannot appeal this yeah
so Dylan and look we've seen this kind
of thing happening with James Charles
and other famous people you can't talk
you can't say about them or it gets
it gets removed sister sniped
Dylan page is out here ruining people's
lives yeah tick tock's running D for him
but wait
it gets even better we have a tick tock
rep now
what happened with them love so I didn't
send that email to them didn't get a
reply but mysteriously
40 minutes after I sent that email boom
The Tick Tock was up so somebody saw it
yeah
here it is check this out
[Music]
and this Tick Tock I guess was was
blowing up pretty good really big on
Tick Tock just to show you guys so this
is Dylan page it's like Philip DeFranco
so Dylan the truth the truth will will
be revealed 850. yeah we're making moves
here yeah it gained like a 150k the last
time 30 minutes Dylan you got it you've
gotta answer for this bro it was too
up blown up on social so this
dude's name is Dylan page she's really
big on Tick Tock just to show you guys
so this is Dylan page it's like Philip
defrance you guys saw you guys watched
this already
why did he do that see the people get it
wow that's dangerous I remember when he
released that video I was so shocked why
he gave so much personal information who
cares what's the point what's his
problem this was so upsetting are there
laws against this there may well be I
don't know
I think a lot depends on which state
he's in
I'm not gonna lie sometimes I enjoy his
content but also I don't think people
realize he's a citizen journalist he's
not professionally trained good point
yeah I'll be honest I've come across his
videos before and I was like these are
fine these are good I mean they're good
informational simple but this you got it
you got it
something's got to be addressed here
Dylan we can't just bury our head in the
sand so I hate to be the bearer of bad
news
my boy dildo
and I got news for you what does it mean
since you just mentioned Philip DeFranco
shoot I it's further down the dock but
do you want to uh talk about this uh
ability thing
oh why because it's related to tick tock
yeah sure uh point you just mentioned
him related to I guess Dylan in that
it's on tick tock
um there's a new news Daddy on Tick Tock
because Dylan called himself that but
he's full of and he's been if he
was news daddy he's been demoted yep you
want to see who's the real news Daddy
get a load of this hunk of me
wow holy holy who needs two
kidneys when you got two guns
you know what I'm saying dude he looks
good
bill can I talk about your body when
you're jacked
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know what the is wrong with
me it was my dad used to sneeze like
that wow
my dad used to sneeze like that and I
thought he was crazy but now I when I
sneeze it's so explosive yeah I'm a
powerful
I can't silence it yeah no I'm with you
thank you for backing me up so no
comment on Phil
yeah I'm gonna say that he looks great
congrats Phil no no don't say that
you're the only one blacklisted here
he said I don't want people
talking about my body no you're on this
video
you talking okay pull up what did he say
we gotta analyze it we got to play
Samantha no let's not relitigate it
because he was actually upset about that
I'm just joking around so here's a post
he posted from
June and I'm not going to comment on it
but here my bun my my bi-monthly health
and fitness update where I seek praise
from strangers on the internet except
not one Ethan you're not a stranger he
knows you okay that's the exception yeah
in the last month I started caring less
about the number on the scale and
shifted to think about what my body can
do it's a healthy mental change good for
you
good for you bro
also can I his hands are looking nice
and medium yes
big hands on that veiny suckers
like to imagine those hands doing
something
oh no
keep it keep it alive
um one thing not related to Philly D's
body that we can talk about that I do
think you should comment on though hold
on can we please get some corpse
husbands styled hands thirst traps from
Phil
please orps husband hands he just films
because he didn't show his face he just
shows his hand like
when his veins bulging and everyone's
like oh yeah
that happens in Corpse husband I haven't
heard that name in years oh he has
hand is so hot right now
anyway Phil if I were to say anything
it would be nothing because I've been
prohibited and I respect your request
fantastic I call you news Daddy
mm-hmm
that's right
but there is actually
something I do want to talk about like
uh something that we've all kind of
noticed and something I think a lot of
you all have noticed too
in fact jeez he's even crying blood it's
so serious uh Philip defranco's Tick
Tock is turned into like literal Doom
Doom baiting it's like all about war and
death and it's CR it's I it's
working for him the views are nuts but
like crazy if you watch Philip DeFranco
Tick Tock I'm pretty sure you're just
living in a bunker or a safe room
because the world is ending this is so
like different than his YouTube videos I
think he he found like it's exclusively
like military like Battlefield updates
he's a warlord who's daddy baby
um yeah it's all U.S soldiers fled North
Korea to escape racism in America what
that's interesting that's bad for
America damn they're like Northam even
North America is better than this it's
really fun
Al Qaeda calls for revenge on Sweden and
Denmark North Korea is preparing
offensive War
uh
France is fighting U.S picks aside in
the world war Africa he's calling it
World War Africa has begun Africa
appears to have begun Eagle was
activated standby forces to restore
democracy and constitutional order and
the Republic of Niger without
maintaining that all options remain on
the table Also earlier today Niger told
the US that if they're neighboring
Nations intervened they'll kill the
ousted president that they're holding
hostage which is the biggest mistake the
Junta has made so far as this seems to
be what pushed people they're wearing
white pants on the outside of their ego
bosses combat fatigue the US has picked
it down World War Africa appears to have
begun ecowas is activated in standby
World War Africa
if it's a World War why Africa
there's a little bit can't have a World
War Africa it's just a World War
Continental War Africa
Philip the state department top comment
that's good all right forces to restore
democracy and constitutional order yeah
I noticed that he's just I mean you know
he found something that works but it is
a little
Doom baiting I don't know
you know what I mean a little bit
yeah I agree let's see China attacks
Philippines and South China Sea China
attacked the Philippines in the South
China Sea with a Chinese Coast Guard
ship firing a water cannon at a
Philippine ship attempting to resupply a
marine Garrison the Philippines
condemned the action in the U.S
reminding China that it has a treaty
obligation to defend the Philippines and
that extends to its ships in the South
China yeah China attacked the
Philippines in South China Sea
like it's
trying to make everyone think that like
war is about to break out any second
Civil War you know World War Africa
but I mean what do you think because
he's getting views but and he's a news
man I mean he's news Daddy yeah he's
covering the news but is it selective to
get views I guess that's the question I
think he exaggerates the danger to the
world of uh in a you know
China is abandoning let me look for a
really scary looking one China and
Russia sail off coast of America China
and Russia sent a huge Naval Patrol near
Alaska with at least 11 Chinese and
Russian Ships coming very close to
Alaska but never entering U.S Waters
reportedly four U.S destroyers and p8
aircraft were dispatched to Shadow their
patrol and it was really a historic
versus this was the largest flotilla to
ever approach the United States which is
why the U.S described this as highly
provocative I'll let it stay in the loop
China and Russia to stay in the loop
follow no one the first nukes drop
I want to hear like the slide of all the
fill tick tocks like the noise he makes
oh the big news it's the Calm before
Kenny is ready to lead a multinational
four it's Kenya is ready to lead a
multinational Force into Haiti and China
attacked the Philippines China is fed up
the US is taking over peace talks with
the Belarus has begun military drills on
Russia says they may not hold press the
U.S and Saudi Arabia reportedly have a
working plan in place the US just issued
an urgent security alert telling all
World War Africa appears to have begun
igowas's military intervention in the US
has picked a sign in World War Africa
is World War Africa his own verbiage is
that or is that like
let me see I've heard it everywhere I've
never heard it
I don't know he's he's World War Africa
there's nothing here he is World War
Africa
except World War Africa I don't see
anything
I'm not seeing a lot
that's a Philly exclusive
if he coined that that's awesome
I think he did crazy
um
by the way the flotilla thing do you
know anything about that Dan because I
feel like when that stuff happens it's
usually like routine and happens all the
time
and you can make it sound like a world I
had read a little bit about it from what
I understand it was uh they they kind of
went by the Aleutian Islands which was
the island chain that extends out from
Alaska so um
and like he did say in it I mean they
didn't enter international waters but
yeah I mean um there's no question that
there are tensions between China and
United States are rising but um
yeah that's that's about all I know I'd
have to read into it more well where
Africa well we're Africa I think it yeah
it's a proxy conflict of world war
Africa actually it's the Alaskan
campaign
to ever approached the United States I I
feel like Pearl Harbor was probably a
bigger flotilla
well
they didn't have flotillos I mean that's
just a term for a fleet oh it is yeah
because there's nothing floating there
was flight tillers the aircraft carriers
got relatively close to Hawaii and Pearl
Harbor
flotilla
what's a float I'm gonna Define flotilla
for my dumb ass
flotilla
here it is you guys want to know what
floatel means a fleet of ships or boats
but it was airplanes
those airplanes were launched from
aircraft carriers that were part of a
giant Fleet though they were I think
they well they they were close enough to
bomb so
anyways I
um I'm defending news daddy here there's
an there's another angle to this too
that I'm curious about
this is original content it's not from a
show so they recorded for tick tock
which I thought or it's an AI or it's
like an AI differential voice oh Billy
DeFranco because I watch a lot of these
channels it's they must spend time doing
this
in two seconds to Rattle off the
dialogue I guess I suppose yeah I mean
here this one got eight million about
aliens Former Intelligence officer
testified in front of the United States
Congress today that the U.S is in
position so this one's a little less
yeah but but it's really dumb though
the story hold on UFOs the officer
claiming that non-human technologies
have injured humans and that the US
government became aware of aliens in the
1930s he also says he's seen a video of
a UFO being shot down and that the US
government has a program to retrieve
crashed UFOs and reverse Engineers I
like this comment why do UFOs only spawn
in the US
question
does seem like that sometimes doesn't it
oh nice
air is actually I should just attack the
U.S bills profile picture
oh he's a warlord he's the warlord
wait is that real
yeah this is a real photograph oh is
that really his
I know what are you asking what what is
this his profile no no no no cam made
this okay Jesus I don't know he used to
be taking on the persona it's a rainy
day out here in Los Angeles that would
rule maybe he should just own it I
thought I was like okay he owns it
here's Philly D's collab with uh corpse
Husband by the way look at those meaty
hands in vain bro like the imaginers
hands all over me
this court margin picture I forgot about
that drone right when a US drone was
returning home after it completed its
mission of defeating Isis a Russian jet
flew within meters of it and deployed
flares on it which hit its propeller
severely damaging it with the US saying
this was an attempt to knock the US
drone out of the sky and the U.S saying
we call upon the Russian forces in Syria
to put an immediate end to this Reckless
unprovoked and unprofessional behavior
and apparently both sides use the
deconfliction hotline but reportedly
that line has been very heated lately
and has just been a place for the two of
them to verbally argue instead of
de-escaling to stay in the loop
put on notifications to get notified to
know before the alarms go off
[Music]
nuclear war
M the whole ocean I don't know though I
mean he's doing his thing I don't know
is it a problem I don't know probably
not he's fine
it's just funny it's like whoa when did
Philly turn into it's interesting how
different it is from his YouTube content
for sure yeah
follow to stay in the loop
put your notifications on to find out
when the zombie apocalypse is happening
anyway good for you Phil found success
on Tick Tock it's not easy
it's so easy
uh okay you guys want some health
updates people have been demanding it
since we went live
Health updates is Ethan dying I demand
all of his medical records I want to
know his blood type I want to know his
plate licked out his white cell count
I'll tell you all of that you're gonna
HIPAA violate yourself
um I got my rights the HIPAA you're
gonna HIPAA violate yourself buddy
you better wash yourself you want a hip
you don't you just done gone hip though
brother you know what happened after you
hit by yourself boy hey come give you
the covid shot
all right so yesterday I saw a
rheumatologist
very smart very nice guy I spent a long
time talking to me a young guy
nice
how are young
uh he probably was younger than me how
tall was he trust that he was probably
about five ten it was that the first
thing you noticed uh it wasn't the first
thing I noticed oh I got a new hold
on I got new results here oh
so I did a ton we did a ton of blood
work that day so I'm still getting the
results of it
uh rolling in now
so there's been there was a few unusual
results
but let me tell you about our
conversation first
um
so basically
he does a conversation this this facial
rash I'm getting here I'm getting it at
the corner of my eyes
I'm getting it on my
uh
eyelid here or here I'm confused
and I'm getting it here on my nose so
that was one of the concerns is that
lupus causes facial rash but he told me
and which is kind of what I read is that
Lupus rash is pretty much all
um
on the cheeks yeah it's all right here
in this kind of area
and so I have not had any rashes there
that's good so he looked closely at the
rashes and stuff and he says he believes
it to be eczema most likely
it's great that'd be good yeah that'd be
awesome after all this I'm not done yet
okay all right it's just a Maxima I'm
not word okay all right all
right no I'm
eczema doesn't cause a positive a a Dan
okay tell me about your Anna titers tell
me about your anal titers or whatever
tighter in yours dude
so that was the first thing
the next thing is we did a full physical
examination checked all my joints again
because with autoimmune he says it's
almost her unheard of with people with
lupus
or similar autoimmune
uh uh diseases is that they don't have
some kind of pain some kind of symptom
in their joints
some kind of arthritis and I I'll tell
you what my joints are beautiful I have
beautiful joints stunning joints in fact
no back he goes do you have back pain I
says Doctor I can't even explain to you
why I don't have back pain my wife is
healthy she exercises She has chronic
back pain I slunch I'm fat I'm sedentary
I have no back pain doctor I said this
to him
backwards
I did actually yeah because that's also
an autoimmune thing it's the right some
kind of connective tissue I remember you
talking about it on I was like okay
everybody says I have weird elbows so I
show them this I did this for him
bunch of weight it's even weirder I said
Doctor I'm weird elbows take a look I
seriously did like this
[Laughter]
and he agreed right they were weird like
damn those are weird as dude he's
like what the stop can you stop
stop
so he well so there's a test you can do
really simple test
to see if you have hyper Mobility which
is you know the symptom of these
connective tissue disorders and so one
of them
is can you pull your finger back
you can't see it but you put your hand
flat on the table can you pull your
finger back like over 90 degrees not
even close not me I can't do that
another one is can you put your thumb
down to your wrist can you force it down
to your wrist I can do that
interesting can you guys can anyone else
do that no I knew the first one yeah
oh you can do that one yeah that's all
you got I think it matters that you have
to lay the hand flat though I can do
gross with my fingers hold on hold
on Amy show me how you're doing it
because you got to bend your wrist bro
I'm like
you bend your wrist forward how do I
like this like this
like this yeah right and then yeah
press your thumb down like you can do
that yeah I feel like it's not that
weird that I can do that you can bend
your wrist a lot compressing to me I can
only do nine that's all you can do yeah
really yeah that seems odd
but you could show me your wrist guys I
got alien thumbs ready for this
stop it
oh my God cam can you do this you got
some wild ass fungus dude
don't think I can do that
Wiki can you guys can you guys do this
yo no
the I'm doing okay wait can you do
this is what you're talking about Dan
can you do this
yo he definitely has lupus holy
Bro one more time I did the doctor I was
like yeah okay can you do this
so I guess and then the other one is can
you stand and touch the floor flat with
your palms okay easy even close to do
that wait if you're flexible like that
doesn't I think it's all together like
it like you like Camp yeah maybe maybe
if it's all of these yeah Collective can
you do that would make sense okay would
it be hyper Mobility but camp Oh I used
to be able to do that wait cam come here
are you hyper flexible yeah dude ready
watch this
what
wait what yeah have you always been like
that always do you eat your Donuts so
wait wait let's do the hyper Mobility
test come here okay come here uh let's
do it
that's crazy the the fur behind the head
get there just like no problem bro yeah
damn
all right so the first one here comes
sit with me or I actually just come
stand here come stand here okay all
right so the first one is the finger one
so can you put the finger back 90
degrees Yeah if you put on the table
flat on the table like this and then
pull your pointer finger back
okay that's wow that's definitely
flexible okay you can stop you can stop
now you can stop no it's not related to
lupus oh well I'm gonna put it closer to
you yeah let's not let's not put that
too far from me glad I don't got lupus
ah the world is on is falling oh my god
oh oh my God
little crooked I can do this
oh the snake Okay so you can do that one
the other one is the thumb one let me
see how you do that just go no no you
you can you touch her how do you do it
yourself yeah basically that's it you
can do that
oops
yeah you can do it yeah okay then the
other one is
can you touch the ground with your palms
standing up straight yeah see let me see
with my Palms yeah with your palms
holy your name your knees aren't
bending no what the hell wait let me do
it can I do it on the table sure yeah do
it on the table
oh God all right yeah
oh my God amazing this table's about to
break
I can feel it
buckling
under the immense
weight of your flexible ass
and then the other one was there was
four then that one that one
oh the other one is can your do your
arms Bend more than 90 degrees if you go
like this
try to bend it so no that one does it
but I feel about 90 degrees backwards
gotta be able to bend like down
More Than 180. This goes down a little
bit yeah oh okay oh I see I don't think
so broken arms you like this
let me see it the camera like me
feel like this
did you just yeah what's the method
there I don't got it you don't got it oh
God I don't got this stuff and then also
it works with your leg does your leg
Bend more than 90 degrees
if you can you bend this up wait a
minute wait this leg goes yeah I don't
think so you know interesting I can do
this
damn bro what the hell both legs between
your legs
I'm afraid I'm gonna fall out
no I don't think I can do both legs okay
how can your dick between your legs do
you stretch or this is just natural
building all right thank you cap that's
it do I have lupus it's not related
you might have to a connective tissue
disorder though I'm just kidding
connective tissue can I diagnose you
real fast
order symptoms
you're sick do you do you feel generally
unwell
shout out every day of my life amen you
feel fatigued or have mild fevers every
day oh fatigue for sure
do you have dude your fingers or hands
ever get swollen no that's good muscle
or joint pain no do you ever get weird
rashes
um
you're fine sweet
muscle or joint pain
no my joints are perfect do a cold and
numb fingers or toes
um
so you're good you're good you're good
you're just a stretchy boy I think so
Gumby looking ass and Gumby gonna be
good
uh so anyway back to Africa World War is
Coming guys subscribe to Ethan Klein to
know when the nuke drops oh that's good
it's decent
I appreciate the plug silly
um so anyway
we tested the weird elbows okay because
everyone was telling me I have weird
hyperflexive elbows so that one was fine
basically he says so the a a test is
basically a diagnostic tool for lupus
and lupus
like diseases
so he says 15 of the population will
have a
a false positive a a test
some
but
um
he says it's it's really hard to
diagnose anything like this or to do
anything like this when I don't have any
symptoms I mean I feel fatigued I feel
tired but
that's about it and especially without
the rash
so we ran a whole bunch of more blood
tests
I don't know if it seems like a lot to
you guys but I filled up 10 vials of
blood whoa that is that I was there I
was like gnarly
wait 10 vials and vials and the doctor
you said seemed very young
where are you calling with this a
vampire
well he didn't take the blood it was
actually a really nice old lady and I'll
be honest I'll be I'll I'll admit I have
um thralls you know this is the blood of
God
well the nice lady who took my blood
actually was comforting because I was
like yo tan and she's like well when you
donate blood it's a lot more than this
so it's not actually that much she said
to me also this nice lady because I have
tiny veins
um and people are always poking me and
missing and every time I give blood it's
a nightmare because sometimes
they have to poke me four goddamn times
before they find the vein
and she had this great technique she
brought out a heating pack
heated up my arm which apparently makes
my veins bulge more
and uh
she got in the first try
so this is all sounded very much like a
vampire yeah well so who's the vampire
the blood lady or the doctor I'm
thinking maybe the whole Clinic they're
all I think that I think the doctor is
the vampire I think that the nurses and
the the solutions those are
mind-controlled thralls of the vampire
like in Dracula like that room that
Jonathan yeah yeah vampires they they
can they can enthrall people and make
them their their servants okay so okay
you've been playing vogdoor's gay too
much Dan
maybe
I just I mean I just that's undoubtedly
true regardless of if I'm right or not
uh apparently Dave uh just a side note
Dave porkboy dm'd Bobby and he has the
scoop is he spilling the beans
unauthorized I don't know like this was
uh uploaded then deleted
really yeah that's exciting wait what
are we about I heard that Bobby slept
with Drake and is getting divorced so I
asked her I DM Bobby what you asked her
did you sleep with Drake and are you
getting a divorce yeah she's like I'm
not coming commenting on that publicly
wait so you just outed her oh you just
outed her not public comment
wait hold on okay if he's joking that's
super up like that's not funny
right you can see why he erased it
either way I was laughing at how Josh
talks
the way he'd be presented back to Dave
and just repeat it
wait so you just outed her is he the
Coconuts of this of this group he is oh
yeah yeah oh yeah coconuts and Barbados
you decided her not public comment
so
either way you cut this it's insane like
to put that out as a joke like oh yeah
she him like that's not funny
she's married she just had a kid yeah
Oh weird
what does it mean there's no way that's
true right this is there's no way that's
true no
right you said the tick tock's deleted
that's obviously from an episode of
their podcast that was the podcast she's
been on on their podcast right yes yes
so he could have on in
maybe I believe that he could have
messaged her right yeah
I don't know that she would confirm or
deny that she Drake to Dave pork
boy it's unclear if she just meant like
oh I'm not going to talk about this
topic well the way they bleeped it right
it made it they're like look at it see
that was bad that was bad I see why they
erased it that was up
this is what my doctor looked like
what's the big deal
I don't understand why you guys are
worried
can't do this
so
no
um
so anyway where did a ton of blood tests
some to check um
my basically inflammation
some to test
here I have a whole bunch of results
results here I'll read it to you guys
you guys can tell me what I'm dying of
they're all coming in
right now
so there was a few abnormal ones I
noticed my thyroid is fine he you know a
a hyperactive thyroid could cause a
positive Ana test which I don't have
this one's a little bit above the C4
complement
C4 complement
is a 44.
where the normal range is 10 to 40 which
is not that elevated what's the C4
complement
a protein involved in the intricate
complex system
it has a critical functions in terms of
immunity tolerance and autoimmunity with
other numerous components here I say
it's a C4 is associated with some
autoimmune diseases like let's see
uh
doctors will order a C4 test if they
suspect you have lupus or other
autoimmune diseases so that one's
elevated
so what the you know what I mean
Dan you want to make fun of my condition
more
I got C elevated C4 bro does that mean
anything to you
you should plant the bomb site B
you think I should what did you say I
should Counter-Strike
Pro what do I need to button you
know
you saying I should bomb a
what did you say I should bomb then bomb
them things like a Call of Duty
reference Counter-Strike Counter-Strike
reference back me up love yeah
that's all I was doing about when I
talked about the NRA I was also doing a
kind of thing I think it's a I think
it's okay though now Mr Beason is in his
latest video just like had a transition
where they like bombed friends yeah it
was up I would never talk or do
anything like that
super so it's 44 so it's slightly
elevated
which is you know potential for that one
the C3 is normal
okay Shadow C3 the rheumatoid Factor
normal
God Testament for rheumatoid
whatever rheumatoid arthritis I guess I
don't know normal they just send you
these results yeah without any extra
information no it's it's great they
usually put like a note if it's elevated
to a certain degree but yeah they
there's they show you the normal
reference and they tell you I I
personally like it the doctor comes they
give it to you as soon as it's available
and then the doctor comes and analyzes
for you in a few days that's fair yeah
can I ask you a question
um please don't get offended that at
this I myself am a hypochondriac would
you describe yourself as the same
personally no I don't think so okay I
mean I think everyone's paranoid about
their health at certain times right I
don't I don't think I have like
crazy crushing uh anxiety whenever you
know what I mean but this is Gen you
know this is oh absolutely yes I don't
think I'm being a hypochondria
absolutely not so creatine is normal I
think that's the kidney thing because I
know because Shredder
so we're good on that guys
okay that's the k c
the C reactive protein is normal
we're good see reactive everybody
the sedimentation rate
this one was
very elevated
sedimentation rate you got sediments in
your blood is a 28 where the max volume
considered normal is 12.
so over double you're eroding my dude oh
what is what is said it sedimentation
rate sediments right erythro
erythrocyte
urethra it can show if you have
inflammation a blood test that can show
if you have inflammation in your body
see that's not good then from
inflammation is your music yeah
inflammation means you know something's
going on
so I'm I'm pretty positive there well it
says the normal uh 0 to 15 in men
I'm sorry what was yours
mine was 28.
twin
is that okay with you Dan or you want to
demean my my health oh yeah I don't know
I would never I would never
I would never do that I'm out here I'm
out here with elevated sedimentation
rates yeah and you're just gonna joke
don't even get me started on my C4
oh here's a new one or one translucent
trans glutaminus
antibody
normal
or normal
on that one
transgender trans
glutamanus sometimes called meat glue
oh man I want meat glue this is an
enzyme a chemical that speeds up the
chemical reaction between molecules yeah
of different substances damn meat glue
bro I'm not I don't have meat glue yeah
you're good on the meat glue that's bad
as gliadin antibody
I'm normal on
fantastic
oh then my
we should so what are the ones on normal
on I'm curious so we can try to rule it
out and make a diagnosis here live yeah
let's do that so what it so the thyroid
peroxidase which I'm assuming is just
thyroid function
uh-huh
if somebody can fact check that oh it's
an enzyme crucial to produce a thyroid
hormones so I'm good at my thyroid is
good
okay my C4 is elevated what was that one
about
no uh I don't know I was making it is I
was making jokester no one
I think it was also an autoimmune thing
um it can be found in people with cancer
or inflammatory bro why'd you have to
say that I was trying to don't lead with
cancer
or inflammatory bowel disease which
sounds more like you
you do have bowel stuff a lot what's
inflammatory bowel disease is that
autoimmune
um
that'd be fun
and die you son of a I'll cut your
throat I'll come down
the Dr Phil you are off the rails uh
Crohn's disease is one of two types of
inflammatory bowel disease
well there's another there's another
type as well but that gives you a sense
of what we're talking about here so it's
pretty serious uh yeah inflammatory
bowel disease is Crohn's
and ulcerative that's my mom has
ulcerative colitis oh but like she
that's like when you blood and
stuff which I don't do okay so you know
Dan I don't blood
are they uh what aren't you due for a
colonoscopy sin no I actually went my
doctor said go go in and get it at uh I
think he said 45 oh God because you're
you're not at risk or anything right
so three years two years
now that's that'd be seven years so
um
what is Crohn's disease let me read the
inflammatory bowel disease that affects
the lining so science Mr Beast has
Crohn's yeah I know I know a lot of
people signs disease
severe diarrhea fatigue weight loss and
malnutrition
yeah I don't I don't know about that
you know
not sure about that one no Thrones I
don't think so and then my C3 is normal
what's C3
C3PO C3 compliments
um
it shows how parts of your immune system
are working
um
and how they're responding to harmful
substances so I'm good
and that one
Mary said when I was diagnosed with
cancer I had an ultrasound result that
was sent to me with no context or doctor
note that basically said prob cancer on
it holy Jesus I also got the
results before my provider holy
that's scary that's awesome
the doctor's like well
[Music]
uh
the news is that
I guess they're right
the good news is
you've got a great radiologist they were
right on
super accurate diagnosis yeah I mean at
least I guess
a rheumatoid Factor what is that one
I'm good on the rheumatoid Factor no no
uh
[Music]
measures the amount of rheumatoids in
your blood okay can't do this rheumatoid
factors are proteins produced by your
immune system that can attack healthy
tissue in your body I'm good
no rheumatoid
oh I'm so glad that I have the doctor
the good doctor treating me I feel so
much safer now
he's a surgeon though I know that he's
mentioned that yeah so what is I mean no
well if I need well stuff like that
right if I need surgery he's the man why
does he have a watch on dumbass that is
a good question bro don't start digging
into me with a watch unhygienic
dude can't do this like Captain Hook
dude I think kind of a wild fit too is
it what what is he wearing he's getting
an x-ray I think oh that's like a lead
best thing
um okay I've got the CK total I'm good
on
tell me about the CK total
okay total
uh creatine test measures
elevated CK levels main Decay skeletal
muscle heart or brain damage or
degeneration either chronic or acute
glad I don't got elevated of those are
we looking yeah we're also stands for
Cricket Kenya
well I just want to see what I don't
have Dan I want to see what I don't have
I mean that's going to be a very long
list no it's not conditions and diseases
I'm willing to wait here I don't have no
it's not it's just a few set amount I
mean it's a set amount of 10 tests we
did okay C-reactive protein
I'm good on the C-reactive protein Gold
you might call my C-reactive proteins a
reactive proteins a plus reactions yeah
protein made by the liver the level of
CRP increases when there's energy
um Zuck shut the up I'm trying to
listen trying to get my diagnosis
did you I didn't hear you baby I'm sorry
the level of CRP increases when there's
inflammation in the body
okay
um we did the sedimentation rate this is
the one that's elevated
this one's significantly elevated
thank you slide whistle
uh Cedric here I am uh and this is great
this is basically
well Mr Beast has an autoimmune disease
and so I think it's perfect that we're
sitting together here and kind of
discussing the Outlook together the way
you're holding your hands on your lap
that's me
so it's e s r is that yeah I got it uh
it's a blood test that can show you have
inflammation in your body
[Music]
um
high levels may be caused by autoimmune
diseases such as lupus or rheumatoid
arthritis
chronic kidney disease kidney disease
infection
yeah so again
[Music]
I don't think I I didn't have any
rheumatoids in my blood so thank you
yeah another lupus Arrow you know what I
mean
[Music]
it's another lupus Arrow
here this is transglutamycin IGA
antibodies we looked that one up well I
don't know what it means or did we look
up everybody let's look it up that one
what was it just in case can you say
that one more time try glute
transglutaminase
here that's the meat blue bro remember
we talked about the meat glue and what
does it mean though if you're high in
Meek meat glue yeah but you don't have
high meatloaf right no but what does it
mean if you do have high meat glue uh
uh let me find I don't have meat glue
though but I'm just curious
celiac disease yeah
know your way around oh okay
because we were we suspected it might be
Celiac but this one says
not celiac
there you go
so I don't have celiacs disease because
that was another one that can cause
elevated Ana and my mom has celiac
[Music]
okay so what else what else can we rule
out you think
let me see
here here's a list of um diseases let's
just go one by one Dan I have a list of
you think you have cholera I have no I
don't know why would I why would I know
I'm just looking at my blood work
this sounds like that's probably a no
the next one is um
gliadine antibody IGA
gliadine
antibody
do we have gliadin antibody IGA
uh that seems to also gastrointestinal
inflammatory disease some autoimmune
conditions liver disease plasma cell
disorder it sounds it's a pretty pretty
wide net there on that one no you're
good though you're good and then this is
the last one if that's okay with you you
should put in the values in between and
then say what diseases can I have I know
what it will say it says you you
probably have Lupus yeah but it might be
something else too
do you think you might have Hansen's
disease handsome's disease yeah
my mom used to tell me that all the time
Charming disease charming and amazing
disease all right this is the last one
glia den antibody IGG
I'm sorry
GG he's the same one as the last one but
IGG at the end
gliodin antibody IGG
you have high or that's a Star Wars
character I'm good on it that's good I'm
negative I think
uh associated with antibodies that are
associated with diagnosing celiac
disease
uh let me read more
go on
oh that's nice nice font
um
when I went to read more I just
went off the charts all right hold on go
on
continue
tell me about the GG
often used as a way online to signify a
good game also bro that's not the GG
[Music]
[Laughter]
can you read the whole name of it again
Ethan I can send it to you
it's going to help me with this research
yeah what was the name of it again
Ethan I was actually I was yeah
I have follow-up appointment so I was
messaging uh Lena about acquired immuno
listen guys I'm live so much I gotta do
I gotta build this medical now I
mean no yes and by the way I keep
nothing from you guys yeah Tom Ford my
life is an open book
and if I have inflammatory bowel disease
my will also be an open hole
right for you guys to look into
fantastic like that uh like The Nair guy
nice one guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
do you have chronic poopy poo poo
it's gliadin antibody IGG you found it
the findings of IGG antibodies May
indicate a diagnosis of celiac disease
so I don't have the Celia it's sounding
like we can definitively well that's
interesting so that that is actually
really useful to know that's good no
celiac that's great it sounds like Oompa
Loompas
all the positives say you have lupus
is it possible that all of these
problems and symptoms that you're
getting are because of the um
big pharma's back no kilzine yeah I mean
all the doctors know the medicine I'm on
some medicines can cause a um positive
Ana but none of the ones I'm on are
associated with yeah they're part of the
cover-up
right yeah could always be a cover-up
the m in the M
RNA Mafia
mafioso okay so this is insightful
my girlfriend has celiac disease and you
definitely have ligma Celiac oh
you're a silly ass ligma you know what
I'm saying ligma ciliac
wow all right there it is there it is
dude you can't say I'm a hypochondriac
I'm literally being referred by
hematologists rheumatologist my normal
doctor like these guys are like you're
dying bro you need to go see a
specialist specialist they're juicing
you dude if you I'm not even I'm not
it's costing my insurance unfortunately
anything it's like a 30 copay it's not
beautiful they're getting paid I love it
what um
dude foreign
no I'm kidding if chat knew actual like
hypochondriacs they wouldn't be calling
you that because it's it's a lot it's a
lot well if you're really I think people
use that word Loosely like it is a
medical condition right it's not your
fault it's not your fault thank you all
right let's move on so pretty exciting
there's my um
in short health update is basically
inconclusive still don't know still
ongoing
probably my uh rheumatologist will when
he reviews these tests we'll probably
order more tests to narrow in
but as as I get any information I'll
come to you guys first
and foremost
and and is the chat have any diagnosis
for me
uh let's see uh in all caps Ethan who
cares
um who cares it just happened to be on
my screen you don't care if I'm dying I
think they might care I care wait hold
on DeFranco has an update in a recent
podcast episode YouTuber Ethan Klein
discloses that he's suffering from lupus
disease oh that is really bad reporting
that is insane that is irresponsible he
knows before the doctors he's the goat
Ellie can we do a poll
let's see does Ethan have Lupus oh yeah
he asked the doctor goes do you know uh
your ethnicity I was like oh brother
I was like yeah dude
you're not gonna like this but I'm
99.3 Ashkenazi Joe
that's why that's literally why they
asked your ethnicity just to know if
you're Ashkenazi Jew because we're
so they're gonna be like oh yeah
he's like oh yeah you're
did you really present it that way
you're not gonna I did
well no it's kind of wild I said well I
uh
you're not gonna like this I said I
think I'm the Holy Grail of genetic
disorders uh hmm
[Music]
yeah Ashkenazi yeah all right let's
let's all have the chat tell me what's
my diagnosis and then we'll move on well
we only have four I mean It's gotta be
from four options right well so Ethan
has Ethan has a lupus
B
some other autoimmune
[Music]
C ligma
I mean that's gonna win yeah D nothing
our AIDS I guess nothing
parentheses or eight
or Aids give or take
somewhere between opal let's see this is
HIV in it this is a great poll I voted
for lupus
chat will decide your fate
ligma is taking a commanding lead
42 ligma
and second is 92 percent nothing or age
lupus actually has the least amount of
votes
12. 21 some other autoimmune disease
so I'll ask my doctor about uh ligma
and doctor and perhaps AIDS because that
is in second place doctor I have I have
people telling me I might have ligma
email uh
[Music]
then he would go you probably go to
Google and say what is ligma
then ligma meaning ligma is a made-up
disease on internet hoax claimed to have
killed popular fortnite players and
specifically ninja when people not in on
the joke ask what is ligma the prankster
will apply lick my ball yo now
I guess that's awesome dude that'd be so
funny
all right let's talk about Bradley
Cooper
this freak Bradley Cooper is out
here this is pretty wild coup my
boy what's with you Cooper so Bradley
Cooper is working on another biopic like
we need more biopics
can you just what about
this one is interesting though you sure
well not this biopic specifically I
don't know but the subject of it I would
be interested in watching about so it's
called Maestro maestro
where he was he stars at a world
renowned conductor and composer Leonard
Bernstein the goat Legend
my grandfather the film is being
produced by Martin Scorsese and Steven
Spielberg produced that doesn't mean
Bradley wrote it is directing
um and stars in it yeah and stars in
I'll tell you if Martin's uh Scorsese or
Steven Spielberg were on the set they
would have stopped him
party's girl scores
if either one of these guys were on the
set they would have stopped this
but this was all on Bradley like we said
directing Road starring it okay
you got you got the backing from the
king of Jews Spielberg and thought he
could I was gonna say at the meetings
Ethan I mean he talks all the time
Spielberg got absolutely
um
sideswiped by this
uh Spielberg is pulling yeah is he out
he's out if he's not are you actually
reporting that or I'm saying if he's not
out then we need to put we need to lean
on him Jew card revoked
[Music]
a card which I don't even want and I
hope someone revokes it please leave me
the alone
maybe he feels the same way
take my religion please
um so this guy uh
here's a picture a side by side of the
prosthetic nose
that Bradley Cooper did and then this
composer Leonard Leonard Leonard
Bernstein
do you guys notice something
so they put a big ass prosthetic
nose on a Jew massive
okay but then when you go over to the
actual guy his nose is totally normal
am I Jewish now what was the purpose of
this big ass prosthetic nose
it's like a it's like comically
anti-Semitic
would you have a little do you have
horns in your hair too Cooper
I don't know what the they were
thinking with this here's a better one I
mean their their note his natural nose
is frankly comparable like yeah I could
have just not done anything but the fact
that they did the prosthetic that means
that they said they thought to
themselves the nose this is the one
thing I need to change about myself this
it this defines the man's face it's his
nose really right if you like if that
were the case then I would understand
but
this just seems weird I mean is anyone
like Leonard Bernstein aka Big oh the
nose guy the guy with the giant nose now
like the thing is is that later in life
you know if you look at old photos of
him he had a large nose but a lot of old
people have large noses gross yeah it
grows so it doesn't seem that needed
I'm not needed at all
I'm gonna get for this but I don't
I don't see it as an issue oh my god
dude you were Mr like I know I'm Jewish
wait so so explain why that you don't
just looking at more and more photos of
Leonard Bernstein
um I I don't think it's that look at
this
but what the is that one that what
the is this Zack it also just looks
ridiculous come on the guy had a big
nose not that big it's like it was big
but it's like it's big but it I'm sorry
it's just not was it big enough to like
a prosthetic what does he got a hook arm
this is a statement I feel like an
artistic statement at the very least all
I'm saying there was a lot that went
into this a lot with the family I I
don't think they would have like
I feel like it's all been approved look
at this looks absurd I think it
has to just be like a Nazi propaganda an
intense implementation of like ignorance
just like blind ignorance because what
what is the I just I don't see the
intent like why is it so because he had
a big nose but is that is that
like yeah it's an anti-semitic
drug problem yeah but like the guy had a
big nose not that big it was pretty big
dude yeah I mean there are other photos
of him where it's like okay yeah his
nose is on the bigger side but again
it's just like not
bad it's not prominent enough to require
makeup I disagree yeah and um if you
would watch this movie would you have
been like like his nose is not big
enough that's not Leonard Bernstein
that's not I wouldn't have said that but
you would have never even dreamed to
think of it that's the point well it's
like who cares all I'm saying what is
happening right now Zach what do you
mean
well first of all Bradley Cooper he
so Zach obviously has you back
just kind of automatically you are
abandoning your people no no no no no no
no no no I'm supporting the people here
I'm supporting the people here and I'll
tell you why I support the family that
approve this yeah that's all I'm saying
they didn't know about the news well
they they must have they released uh
they released a statement this morning
did they they did it okay
I was wondering one thing because he has
super bushy eyebrows I noticed like
that's another prominent thing that he
has but they didn't do that to Bradley
Cooper's eyebrows why not the bribros
can we say the movie first curly hairs
what do you mean see the movie I'm
saying can we see the movie do you want
me to you want me to bookmark this
conversation until we watch I'm saying
let's watch the movie before I just feel
like everyone's just trying to just pin
pick it everything nowadays like
I feel like it's it's not that bad who
are you I'm I'm defending the like I'm
not defending Bradley here but I'm just
saying I don't think it's as Extreme as
people I think a lot of people probably
agree I mean I I personally just find it
absurd and funny like I'm not well okay
and tell me about it tell me if you
think this is a coincidence somebody
asked him
what was the budget on the film and he
said
it was about 14
88 thousand dollars
and I was like why did he say it like
that 14 88
000.
why don't you just
I thought that was weird that that was
very weird why did he do that why would
he say that why did he do that
um
inappropriate also like he's kind of
hunky
like he's he like he looks hunky here he
looks like a weird Freakazoid
here I disagree what the hairline is off
too
right
all I'm saying is a person that I'm not
saying I'm a scholar on Leonard
Bernstein here but I studied the guy's
work and I've watched multiple
documentaries with the guy I don't think
it's that
crazy all right let's continue here's a
gallery of tweets uh oh not Twitter
listen it's my turn for this outrage
don't take this from me
and guess what Bradley Cooper's not even
Jewish over having non-jews play Jews
now hahaha
come on Sarah Silverman must be shake
his fuming human right now uh
this feels especially Sinister because
Bradley Cooper's nose is already the
same shape and size if not slightly
larger now okay Sinister I'll be I'll be
totally honest I'm Hamming this up
because I think it's funny I don't I'd
highly doubt anybody on there was like
let's make him look super Jewish
I mean they're made just every scene he
should be rubbing his hands together and
asking about shekels who's got some
shekels for me
give me the guilt
I'm trying to tell his story in a
respectful way it's just whether or not
people are debating whether or not this
choice is was like morally
I don't think anyone thought about it
yep which is crazy it seems pretty wild
that you know on a crazy film with how
many production people are involved that
nobody brought up like should we be
doing the notes prosthetic nose do we
need the nose
are we gonna get for the nose
somebody hasn't been like are we gonna
get for the nose yes that's what
that's what I'm saying yeah and somebody
was like it's fine and now they're
getting so that person was right
but look look how hunky he is he's a
beautiful man isn't he he he was
he's he hard even in his
later age he was uh so why the
would you go from this to this like okay
Bradley Cooper's handsome why you gotta
make yourself look more freakish nosish
Bradley Cooper looks like he has no
brows wait somebody said Sarah Silverman
is in the movie no no
see hold on hold on I gotta confirm that
they're Silverman so if she got by her
then I mean we're cool man if it got by
I mean if she signed off yeah oh my God
she is she is what Sarah Sarah you
dropped the you dropped the dreidel on
that one
this was like she had like a crusade
about this a few years ago yeah so it
can't be that And to clarify it's not
about the nose thing it's she on her
podcast or something uh want on a rant
about jewface about non-jews playing
Jewish characters in movies and then she
this is an example of that yeah because
with a giant nosed boy
it's a little blown out of proportion
that's all I'm trying to say here I mean
the movie isn't like canceled or
anything like I I don't think the Uproar
is that intense about it well this came
from stop anti-Semitism Twitter account
the Hollywood Hollywood cast Bradley
Cooper a non-jew to play Jewish Legend
Leonard Bernstein and stuck a disgusting
exaggerated junos on him can I can I
tell you hi all while saying no to Jake
Gyllenhaal who is actually Jewish I did
not know that I looked into that who has
dreams of playing Bernstein for decades
apparently Jake Gyllenhaal and Bradley
Cooper were in talks separately to do a
screenplay about Leonard Cohen or
Leonard
musician right and uh the family went
with Brad well now I'm very family
decided yeah the estate and family
and I think it's that bad as a chill in
Hall head now I'm pissed a jail head as
a Jill head the swifties are gonna come
out I'm a Jew you're a joke
the swifties why
Jake Gyllenhaal album ready I gotta ask
a question gotcha the people in charge
of his estate are they Jewish yes maybe
not what's his family maybe he got
married to uh to a non-jew and then they
started raising their kids not us
non-religious
or maybe not even Associated they could
be full-blown I mean they could
be Mormons dude
this movie is about The Love Affair of
him and his wife and she passed away in
the 70s level is was his wife Jewish I
do not know educated in Chile she was
like raise the Catholic and later there
it is
all right
Wikipedia one thing about the converts
is they're always more hardcore than
anyone bro they that's true for
all religions definitely
so may I raise something everyone gets
pissed off when I do this
can they have done it for attention and
publicity that's insane that would be
really I'm with you a lot love but this
time we got Spielberg we got Scorsese
and Bradley Cooper
so obvious really good because it's so
obvious that people are gonna get pissed
off at this we're all saying Sarah
Silverman would have never signed off on
that well I mean it wasn't her decision
are just blowing this out of proportion
because someone on Twitter got mad
really that's all I'm trying to say what
about this
is this blown out of proportion oh my
God that's blown out of proportion
because
that's basically what he's doing I
disagree with that
who is this again Maxine
[Music]
yeah so on a scale of a bunch of that
where do you guys place it
oh on a scale of of Macklemore to
Macklemore to uh Jake Gyllenhaal playing
the character right
I place it at I mean the nose is really
dumb it's really silly I still I put it
at like a three
that's what I was thinking two or three
it's like it's it's it's eyebrow raising
it's a it's a three two is too low
two is too low two's too low they earn a
three for this okay that same sort
of level exactly take it off screen for
a second Ian put my document up here on
accident thank you all right you're good
um
let's see if there's anything so they
put out a statement okay his children
released a statement this morning there
you go that was very easy to Bear well
whatever they're friends with Bradley
you know they probably glizz been
glissing them up for this whole these
years he's been doing this how do you
think he got the part instead of Jakey
boy oh because all Jews like money
because he glows them up dude
[Music]
thank you
a bunch of operas oh my God
I just made a huge boo-boo
I hit the button by accident for no
reason what why because I have it on my
screen I was trying to click a window I
misclicked and I clicked the button but
don't you have a physical button no I
have the no I just don't have a physical
no no we only have the one button can
you get that on a separate monitor or
something
uh I mean I did it it was just kind of a
freak accident I'm sorry I apologize
there was no nothing was needed to be
buttoned there that was purely my
mistake
so last thing you said was uh you were
saying you don't know who Leonard
Bernstein is yeah I don't know anything
about him you're saying West Side Story
yes you were talking about the kids
putting out a statement right before it
cut all right so let's read the kids
statement all right
look at this jew-nosed weirdo
I'm sorry it's just it's up
somehow they made
Bradley Cooper look
not handsome I disagree when he is
handsome and Leonard is handsome what
have you done
all right let's read this book just I
just want to say this not you don't have
to have a big nose to be do you just
because you're Jewish it doesn't mean
you have a big nose or vice versa a lot
of other people have big noses that's
our Point dude what do you mean
what what do you mean what I mean that's
our point
that's what that's why it's scary that's
why it's weird that they did it
but he did in fact have a big nose
not that big okay stop whatever Bradley
Cooper included the three of us along
every step of his amazing journey
as he made his film about our father
we were touched to the core to witness
the depth of his commitment his loving
Embrace of our father's music and the
sheer open-hearted Joy he brought to
this exploration dude he was in so tight
with his family
there would never peep a bad word about
him
it breaks our heart to see any
misrepresentation or misunderstanding of
his efforts it happens to be true that
Leonard Bernstein had a nice big nose
they put that in the statement wow they
literally wrote that
Bradley chose to use makeup to amplify
his resemblance and were perfectly fine
with that
we're also certain that our dad would
have been fine with it as well
any strident complaints around this
issue strike us above all as
disingenuous attempts to bring a
successful person down a notch
practice we observed all too often
perpetrated on our father
but okay
probably because of anti-Semitism yes
so it's not it's kind of a inverse of
that but I guess I see what they're
saying yeah the Jews the the
anti-semites the Jews can't win
at all times during the making of This
film we could feel the profound respect
and yes the love that Bradley brought to
his portrait of Leonard Bernstein and
his wife our mother
why do you keep calling him Leonard
Bernstein it's your dad
our mother Felice Felicia
we feel so fortunate to have had this
experience with Bradley we can't wait
for the world to see his creation I mean
genuinely the film is shot I don't think
it anyone had a bad intention about it
so I mean I get it to put out the uh the
statement
that being said it's just this is just
what this movie is now
you're not winning an Academy Award
looking like that Bradley I hate to tell
you
and if you do win you better not wear
that up to accept the
to accept it all right that would be
inappropriate
let's I'm curious what the audience
thinks on the
um
let's let's do
uh pull okay
on the scale of Jake Gyllenhaal playing
to Brad uh two more Macklemore
nose
now I think in general because we don't
have a lot of
we don't have a lot of options with the
pull
we have four so I say we start at two
three four five it's not six though so
maybe maybe you start with one just do
one two four yeah one one to four
I think some people might vote five
probably not though but like one two one
out of four just make that the whole
breadth of the scale is one two four
that makes sense
yeah just kind of
no I don't like that okay all right so
yeah yeah like one to 100.
we'll start at like eight let's do like
40-ish
all right yeah on a scale of one to four
go ahead all right scale one to four how
questionable is the nose Macklemore
one being Jake the one being Jake
oh his name is so hard to spell
I'm definitely gonna spell it wrong so
forgive me and then we'll do two and
then we'll do three and then we'll do
four Macklemore
got it
all right polls going up
so my vote is going to be somewhere
the thing is because it's such a limited
scale I'm gonna vote a two okay
but it could be a thing see it's not a
three just because
oh wow it's all over the place
um very divided very different
interestingly the least problematic one
is is one so some people are saying yeah
this this nose thing is is it's a big
deal this is a big big deal
[Music]
it's a huge deal two and three are tied
at 32 percent and McLemore bad is a
second to last with 22 percent
Zach Zach with all with all shtick aside
I totally understand where you're coming
from thank you yeah yeah no I've seen
lots of people uh echoing what you've
what you've seen yeah and clearly the
family agrees with you so uh you know
I'm not
I'm not trying to come down hard on it
at all I just think it's really
pretty funny it's quite an oversight
yeah
quite an oversight
you know
I wouldn't even I would even hesitate to
verbalize
a comparison to other ethnicities
because I would have to hit the button
on myself
right yeah
um right yeah let's not do that let's
not do that
so so it seems that two is is taking the
day here I mean there's lots of people
whining about it being a bad poll which
fair enough but also doesn't really
matter you know what I'm curious about
is if there is a dong scene in this
movie how well this yo decision is yeah
yeah you're saying how far how far back
is the hood Club well we need to see the
original dong and if we can get side by
side how good the Moyle did how good did
the Moyle do Bradley are you even
circumcised Bradley now that that would
be anti-semitic I would take
I would take it all back
if he's not circular if he's unclipped
playing Leonard Burns can you Google it
Bradley Cooper circumcised
also has Bradley Cooper has Bradley
Cooper had sex with men
yeah good for him yeah they should cut
it before the recording yo that guy's
pretty that guy's pretty brave out there
being bisexual and Jewish back then he
was closeted he was closeted I I think
that's actually largely what this film
is about is his relationship with his
wife
which yeah I see so did his wife know he
was closeted I think so I think so yeah
oh that's interesting answers.com go
ahead
it's the Vegas
thing I've ever seen it says is Bradley
Cooper circumcised and then one person
with no upvotes said yes
okay maybe that's Bradley dude I found
it's a data point unrelated celebrity
circumcised list 1982 has every male
celebrity on here and it says cut or
uncut next to their name what that's
awesome the book of cuts that's
what that's like Wiki feet of
circumcision Jeff Goldblum
wait how do they know oh I don't know
why I mean all of them are bolded Word
of Mouth maybe Jeff Goldblum was bolded
well he's Jewish it comes up sometimes
in interviews I don't know or I mean I
guess some of them may have done my nude
scene was put in the 80s this was some
groundwork people were doing yeah that's
because that was like the Red Scare
they're like yo who's Scott who's not
Elvis Presley everyone was get was
circumcised back then everyone Elvis
Presley uncut freak just kidding I'm
sorry I'm just kidding I say the right
on that I just I don't like Elvis I
don't think people who are uncirculated
should I hit the button overall okay but
no no no no you're offending the uncut
Brothers I Wonder If lost are uncut they
don't got nothing to worry I wonder if
Austin Butler like if he was clipped or
not to play the role because he was so
about that you know he's okay oh what if
he was clipped and he had it restored
just so that he could get into the role
oh Ringo Star uncut sorry here is um
he's an uncut Steven Spielberg taking
the dub for this Really Brave new film
and Malcolm or actually just was just
finished performing so wow
so that's exciting for him Macklemore's
list
dude this is crazy bro
what are you doing didn't he like deny
it too yeah kind of like he's like dude
I just picked up at Party City what are
you talking about
basically and we talked about it
relatively recently and I seem to recall
he tried to explain it away somehow oh
Elton John uncut the English I think the
English it's largely in America yeah the
Americans back then were to universally
do it so yeah
okay
good stuff huh
not bad
did you guys know about the movie before
this drama
[Music]
no uh you know I I had heard a little
bit of Buzz about it so I was like I was
kind of aware that it was happening but
I'm certainly hadn't seen the trailer I
just I'm so I'm going conspiracy theory
yeah I'm full
none of us knew why would they like
potentially ruin the like this movie is
Tainted my opinion they will not put
make him wear okay prosthetic nose for
the entire movie just so that they can
go viral during the marketing campaign
they would just do one picture or
something right yeah okay I didn't know
the trailer was odd actually so yeah
yeah I think that's the trailer dropping
is what made everybody go yo I thought
they just put out some pictures because
then then I feel like they could have
done if they faked the Prosthetics yeah
if he did wasn't actually wearing it
well if the trail side I'm less
conspirated apparently 80 of um of men
in the United States are circumcised
that's crazy Al Pacino cut
off
cut them off okay Jordan Peterson cut
sporadic uh uh circumcision updates
maybe yeah
William Shatner cut William Shatner cut
okay yeah yeah he's American so yeah
or is he is he Canadian he's Jewish
isn't he Christopher Walken cut
how the do they know that
shatter is Canadian take it back so um
thank you to Bradley Cooper and uh good
luck on the film and all the best to the
family and
all that being said this movie was
boring as and I like Michael
Bernstein I'm not gonna see it that's it
these biopics they got a chill on the
biopics well there it like we mentioned
bio pick me films more like they they're
focused they're choosing to focus on his
uh
marriage in his relationship yeah and a
lot of biopics do that as like a way I
haven't seen it yet but apparently even
Oppenheimer is like kind of uses his
marriage as like a framing device for
the whole movie I feel like there's a
little more relevant to the plot though
because yeah I mean he was dating a
communist lady on the side right right
yeah
with Oppenheimer though they had two sex
scenes and no perfect Killian in
there what yeah
what there was sex scenes and openings
communist boobs there were James Comey
but no perfect Killian and my other
issue with Oppenheimer wow all of the
physicists and they look
too hunky they go they're all like
right big dicks uh
yeah right Robert Downey hell no but can
we looked perfectly bunch of pencil
necks in reality probably wasn't
Oppenheimer Jewish himself he was yeah
that was a big part all right guys let's
start let's stop naming all the Jews
here okay you're putting us at risk is
Killian Murphy cut I gotta know
I don't know probably not all right tell
us if he's caught and we're gonna move
on after that this is from the 80s
oh he wasn't yeah when I'm done with
this list I'll check on that no all
right guys here we're gonna do a clean
cut we're going to circumcise this
second okay ready and chop okay we're
done we're moving on
so there's some pretty juicy Tana stuff
friend of the show although
I don't know because apparently she's
like back friends with James Charles
what oh my God Johnny Cash uncut okay
I'm kidding I'm done
that makes sense to me
so um is that right Olivia she's like
made back posted yeah she's she's has
always said that James was friends with
her friends and she just like didn't
like him but now it seems that they've
mended
so the problem isn't that he's a
predator
yeah the problem is that James Charles
is a predator that's the problem I see
is that's not the problem she had that's
not the problem she ever had she just
thinks she's a nice personal
can you send me the photo if she posted
of them together yeah that's not why she
got in trouble but it was something
again I keep seeing big creators
collaborating with James Charles and I
don't know what the are they doing
um this is like straight up
in Hollywood they talk about how
everyone knew this person was a predator
and everybody kept working with them
that's happening right now on YouTube
yeah I couldn't care less about the
other Tana story to be like she did that
she was mean to someone right or she
ducked someone that I don't care that
much but being friends with and
promoting a known like child predator I
guess that's up that's bad in my
opinion I don't get it it's not great
why don't you care it's really really
bad like I don't know if it's on Tick
Tock where where are these happening hit
the makeup bad girl
and then even a friend of the show like
a bad girl I love Terry Joe I love Terry
Joe I I couldn't say a bad word about
about her that her and Terry Joe but
Terry Joe JoJo Legos
The Lego company
Lego whenever
uh but Jojo and him are like besties
is this somebody who's this Happy
Father's Day
his dad's kind of hunky
no
yeah yeah I mean I guess so yeah wait
what is that Lego bag something's weird
here makeup
bag or bag
uh
I think he posts a lot to tick tock we
can see who else is she's so like
unhinged when she says it sounds rabid
make a bag
why did you say it like that whoa
Melody whoa
um did you find the Tana pick I thought
it was on Instagram yeah I can find a
like a tiny little one that doesn't have
a lot of pixels because it was on
Snapchat I'll send that to you I'm gonna
look for a better quality one though
let's see they were twinning at
Coachella oh they were twinning at
Coachella it was an accident
to be fair
oh but she posted a picture of her with
him yeah that's on her snap so that's
not that's not a good look Hello Olivia
Dana and James twinning at Coachella we
showed up matching to Coachella day one
drunk me had no choice but to take this
pick so she's kind of trying to distance
herself a little bit he's like drunk me
had to take the pick they did a tick
tock together on the sixth okay let's
see that okay send it do you see it on
here
nice oh here it is oh they did a tick
tock together here you're right
today the car is all packed packed I'm
driving all around La to drop off PR
packages and flowers to my friends
because my Brand's about to launch in
two days
James this is so cool
wait wait
I know this guy I think he's a fan of
the show
he's a makeup dude right right yeah
that's Manny mua yeah yeah Manny I know
I think you watched the show Manny's
also
a queen apologist
a queen Colleen apologist
maybe he doesn't watch the show anymore
okay so well but like James's object I
mean what James is doing
you can't be doing this man why
this is so cool
it's only because of these people he
does
their strike just like welcome back baby
let's get those young boys in the DMs
[Music]
no comment I guess
well you're known this next person
competition
Jojo I don't understand her involvement
at all
like listen I know you're friends but
guess what the man's a predator
and you're enabling him
that's just what it is man
Tom Ward's tweeted about us I'm a
lesbian of course stop the Press
[Music]
for you stop it we have our next
delivery for Alicia Marie
who's this I don't know
cat flowers
another makeup person why won't you be
in this video
you are literally like you remember when
Harvey Weinstein went to jail
and everyone's like hell these people
knew Ben Affleck Matt Damon they all
worked with him they all knew and then
when he went to jail they're all like I
swear I didn't know nobody knew that's
you guys right now yeah now all of these
people should be pointed out when he
does it again
because they don't even really have
plausible deniability
like
these other people had a little bit of
plausible deniability because it's been
public so long yeah it's been public so
long
crazy
I'm so excited for me
I'm so exciting
Hannah
okay no comment Tana why man why who
would have ever thought that you would
be at my house with flowers
my painted princess wait was her what's
her bottom of her boobs not supposed to
be out because she she pulled it down
and then it
I'd never seen a top like that no under
boobs in it's in oh it is for Real it's
in it's always been in but now it's
acceptable for reals oh really I never
seen anyone out in public with the
underground coming out
okay I was just turning my head for
titles because here she pulls it down
and then it looks like more
more normal
I mean you know I mean I imagine it's
really difficult to wear
um but I think it looks kind of sick
okay yeah I'm not not to be a boomer or
anything I'm you know adapting with this
uh the world around me
just new to the underboob scene you're
being a boober come being an under
programmed absolutely
yeah
Dan is doting over the dogs
[Music]
this is like a long clip too
they're like fully back
they are so bad being a predator is so
back in
we're back
yeah he's do he's delivering a paint
bucket to Roman Polanski I heard
or the romanski still alive
yeah so he so he's actually doing it
he's gonna do his makeup
be real cool
[Music]
there's two of them crazy
is still getting me every time let's
just see that's the Bell ma'am
it's only for all you
[Music]
it does seem like a lot of famous people
who he once associated with are not in
this video though which is good
there's still a few though
but anyway that's not at all what we're
here to talk about
we're here to talk about uh right this
isn't even the story no oh wait Tom Ward
tweeted about us dude I I'm losing my
mind I find this guy's Twitter now Tom
word show right that was
right I got it
thank you Tom Ward is watching Everybody
the Tom Ward show is my favorite show
remember that this is a Tom Green Show
theme song
I have no idea what you I have no idea
okay Tom Ward is watching here it is
guys big moment Tom Ward it's time to
level up here it is our big moment we
have been recognized by the goat I'm
scrolling down all right my hands are
shaking the anticipation I'm sorry to go
to you
that would be good that would be funny
he got he would get me on that one
here it is
okay here it is here it is here it is I
was actually looking for jobs today
because YouTube has def not worked out
oh he hit ah okay I was I uh I was I was
a fan before this is a little I don't
know what what this make this okay let
me read it well hold on hold on let me
read the whole thing let me read the
whole thing okay let's read it he says I
was actually looking for jobs today
because YouTube has def not worked out
and I get a text that h3h3 was talking
about me on a show today I could only
watch like five men's it was tough
yeah you should have kept watching
because we were nice comment and say
keep watching he was right about a lot
as far as my views so I'm not angry I'm
embarrassed yes but not angry oh Tommy
don't be embarrassed but I would like to
make clear how I get guests how I pay
for everything and I want to be close
crystal clear about how nothing shape I
don't think anything shady is going on
buddy
he's hustling
oh this is heartbreaking you know God
finished the segment please he said
buddy he says Ethan I love the talk hit
me up
I we got to get a call in from Tom let's
go to Colin right now call him right now
Tom you want me to try and message him
yeah okay I'll say uh I'm not logged in
here let me follow him on my
on my main account because this is just
a throwaway I think or is this the show
one
I'll message him from the office no it's
just a random one
Tom call in right now dude let's get to
the bottom of this
[Music]
let's make magic happen for Tom Warden
the interview extraordinaire
[Music]
so go ahead Abe what were you saying
nothing I wish him nothing but success
all right what are you saying Amy I knew
at the end of that was gonna say before
we even read it
nothing Heaven calling so we can do that
thing where
the audience gets mad you think he's
pity baiting yeah
that's what you think I want that I want
that the uh I want that right I saw
Rocky Balboa on him you know what I mean
people's champ on the come up
Rocky Balboa wouldn't pity bait that's
all I'm saying do you think that he do
you think that he's not looking for a
job
I know I'm sure he may be looking for a
job no I'm not saying he's lying about
that
I mean
yeah I could see from I could see him
turning it on and then feeling really
bad about the dumb
Dan was saying about him not me
I didn't say anything mean Dan is the
one
who uh was being super mean to him Tom
Reed Tom check uh where are you reaching
out to in the podcast
the Instagram for the Pod sent him a
message okay let me hit him on Twitter
too
Dan's gonna apologize to you
oh we weren't fully clowning we were
more surprised why is he not getting
views because he's putting out decent
content pretend like there wasn't clown
sure
at the bottom he is putting out good
like
visually pleasing content why is why is
this yes
that it was slow slickly produced
because it seem really well put together
big big guess and very low views and all
of it it just wasn't adding up and I
think that's I think that's fair that's
fair for us to make that observation
sure that was the bottom of her but then
that's the core of what we were
interested in
um I just texted him I dm'd him let's
see so I said hey if you let people have
opportunities what are you talking about
yeah I beat yeah
I was the one saying I I had I was
rooted for him okay I'm still rooting
for him he's my favorite content creator
ever that's all you got to do he's A
True Underdog and the realest possible
most literal sense
that's that's kind of a funny thing dude
you are such an underdog you are
literally like the quintessential
underdog
like if I looked at you I think this guy
has no chance Underdog
massive Underdog button
kidding no but Tom is family now so
let's let's bring him in
now knowing because remember I kept
suggesting that perhaps he has an
audience that somewhere that we're not
aware at first I thought it might be
Facebook or something the fact that he
doesn't have an audience anywhere and is
still getting guessed that size is a
testament to his ability I mean that
that is impressive big names to come
talk to you sometimes hustling isn't
enough and that was Dan's point
wasn't
okay no well I don't remember who said
it but it was I think it was Dan
bomb come on
now we're waiting for your call Tone
we're live Tommy Destiny's going
will you answer Destiny is calling Tommy
we could uh set it up for Friday
as well uh we'll follow up let's do both
[Laughter]
overcompensating now
laughs
I'll post his videos on our Channel
actually new Frenemies co-host new new
episode me and Tommy yeah
Ethan Tom on his channel not ours on his
channel yeah that's where the views are
yeah
that's where it's just a matter of
exposure yeah of course you posted where
they will get the most exposure
you guys are so up
bomb the underdog Ward
he's interviewed every famous celebrity
all of them got cool tats Tom Ward
probably knows Bradley Cooper's clipped
or not
you might if anyone knows it's Tom let's
ask him that in the DM before we
interview him
Tommy first question Bradley Cooper
clipped or not
um all right well as we wait for her for
Tom to read yeah I hope we hear back no
we should make sure yeah
we should wait in silence
so you just want to sit in silence still
and it's like a protest like all right
this silence is on you yeah yeah this
dead air is on you yeah all right so
Tana is getting canceled I guess and
she's losing sponsors and all kinds of
Madness uh oh she went on a she went on
a trip to Europe
and she was super unhappy with an
experience she had at a wine tour
in France
she explained that the tour wasn't what
she imagined she wanted to have fun but
this experience was a lot more serious
than she had anticipated
I mean I don't I've never been on a wine
tour but I don't think it's like meant
to be Ruckus so this tour they walk a
span of about six to seven miles holy
she was she didn't know about but
apparently their friend who signed them
up it was on the flyer when she signed
them up but Tana did not know and
um Tana says that when they were in the
car or the Train on the way there their
tour guide asked them do you want it to
be fun or educational and they said fun
and then this what happened but to give
you preface she asked for fun I guess we
asked for fun and you said it was in
Europe yes it was in France
so the tour guide met them at a location
8 AM Tana was hungover apparently
Tana described their tour guide and
calls her out by name full she uses her
full name
and she drops the name of The Wine
Cellar where she works
wow yep it's giving um
um Dylan page getting Dylan page
so here's a clip now this is all is this
all edited
so that it doesn't play her name
uh
this is not no station this is from her
okay I see this is from her podcast that
is still up
um yes and has 600 000 views so
are we should we not play the game yeah
if the problem is that they named no
she's has since come out publicly and
done an interview with uh NBC NBC okay
so this is all widely known I guess at
this point it's moot though yeah and our
viewers won't
no they would never right right they
would never do anything like that no no
no
never
anyway
um
I was using Trilla the other day and I
noticed the app was flipped
that's crazy did you give it a review I
left it yeah well I left a review based
on my experience using the app it was a
one Stars uh it was a one star one star
some people might give it five but and
personally I give it one two yeah I
think actually I gave it like a 1.5 they
let you do like a half star okay because
I heard Kevin Hart was on there yeah
well he's not he's not on that app oh
what the okay oh sorry can you
change it to a one I'll shake it out I
don't know if I can after the I'll I'll
check it out yeah so um Tana uh here she
is talking about it to my surprise
the woman
who is our tour guide who is taking us
the tour
is there to greet us at the train
station keep in mind where we're going
is like three hours away so she didn't
she come all the way there she came all
the way there seems nice is that a
complaint she's doing to an extra mile
that's good I'm actually going to be
calling her by her name oh is she
horrible Cynthia she's actually she's
like I'm making the conscious decision
to blast this random citizen
cheese Tana you've been on the internet
long enough you know what the like
the different even if you hate this
woman
you know
come on now Cynthia I wrote it down let
me make sure it's Cynthia
Cynthia Cynthia that's her name Cynthia
can we cut to me for one second but if
you could put me full screen real quick
I just want to send Ethan a little
message real quick
one second
oh I think so I think so
um
I I just noticed that too I don't know I
mean it's on hers
seems dumb to wear that though
maybe I'll zoom in
maybe just I'll just play the audio
sure let's do that okay yeah thank you
baby good catch baby thank you
um they're just sitting there telling
the story oh we get to the train station
and I'm I haven't eaten I'm so hungover
they tell us there's gonna be food on
the train there's going to be food there
we get on the train there's no food on
the train there's no food at the wine
tour I find out I'm like oh great now
I'm starving I'm exhausted I'm hungover
I'm sad and she starts
there's like people in Nigeria like the
I just love is it I don't know the first
world problems of it is awesome
but she's entitled to complain
you know I mean we whine about all kinds
of things we do so we do absolutely
we're gonna judge her for that nope I'm
complaining I'm sitting here complaining
about Anna titer
so fair enough immediately talking to us
and she asks a question that for me is
going to be the entire preface of my
frustration with this story okay okay
looks at all of us and she says
this door can go one of two ways
would you like to have a fun tour
or an educational tour why the
would I want to have an educational tour
nice commentary
I guess that is like what a wine tours
for yeah but yeah but I think that our
age range yeah she's not necessarily
whatever she shouldn't she shouldn't
even have asked that question frankly
also
yeah if you go to French France and go
to they're gonna be like boring I feel
like French yeah yeah it's like
educational for the people that cares
care about wine drinking wine I think if
you wanted to get drunk they'd assume
you just go to a bar right or sit in the
kit they probably have a room there a
bar there you could just drink
you know and I appreciate the question
thank you for asking we all come to the
consensus hey we didn't really sleep
last night we're super tired we'd like
to go on a fun wine tour right so then I
put in my headphones for what is
probably one minute and I intend on
sleeping on this two and a half hour
train ride you know girl dinner I'm
gonna have sleep for breakfast at least
get some rest before we go on this long
day oh my God you gotta charge up and I
feel a tap on my shoulder oh as I'm
dozing off
it's Cynthia Cynthia I take my headphone
out
and she proceeds to go on a 30 minute
tangent to me about why vuv clicko
champagne is called vuv clicko champagne
okay so I you know it's probably bad
social etiquette on Cynthia's part I
mean she could have said I'm just prefer
to sleep
you know I don't know okay whatever it
doesn't seem like that big of a deal so
what else is there okay so we just took
a clip out because she says the c word
when she's explaining what happens and
um it's a little it's a little risky if
we try to mute it so I can explain to
you what ends up happening and the one
where she says I want her dead
oh no no not that one actually that's a
separate one but the way that the story
ends is that the woman
um ask them to like drink a glass of
wine the way that they would normally
drink it and one of them made a joke
about like slamming it but she didn't
actually do it and then Cynthia said
like oh maybe only the Civilized people
should have a drink and then Tana got
super angry they got into a fight and
then she was like I'm go I'm leaving and
so Cynthia went back with them all the
way Cynthia left or Cynthia uh went with
them back to Paris
on the train like she didn't stay at the
winery she like accompanied them why I
guess just that was her her prerogative
her job she picked him up that morning
okay so here so that happened
um so the problem arises here obviously
she had a bad time so many more things I
want to say but he doesn't like the lady
but here she had an Ethan moment and
tana girl talk to me you got you got to
get a butt and you gotta uh
breaks my heart to see this happen to
someone else talking for 40 minutes I
mean just to casually throw out a death
threat I mean we've all been there
to 50 000 people we've all been there
live 600 000 in her case
well this isn't live though right no no
right yeah no it was recorded at I guess
your point is yeah I had the opportunity
right yeah they they don't need a photo
she's like hold on let me get her exact
name okay it's Cynthia and she says her
last name at some point too right yeah
uh I don't know if she says um yeah
they knew the winery yeah they knew they
knew the first name he owns it too right
honestly I loved it I kind of want
Cynthia dead in events no I
I absolutely want her dad at the hands
of me okay so okay let's Analyze This
death wish
um how do we rate this on death wishes
and catch what she said she said no I I
literally honestly I loved it I kind of
want Cynthia dead no vents no I I
literally I I absolutely want her dad at
the hands of me they're obviously being
ironic they're just being over the top
but you can't say that on the internet
right also you know that's the
difference also if you can say a big
difference from when I like other people
have done death wishes they do it's like
two famous people right this is like a
private it's random citizen it's pretty
wild it was very very exposed
to anything right that's very up
it's very why not
should not have editors
they want no I mean they left it
intentionally there's a post but I think
yeah I mean it's an overall package
right it's not even like oh I want her
dead as a goof it's the name it's the
location the fact that she's just a
private citizen you know it's pretty
wild
so was that your only negative
negative but as far as death threats go
mine was had more Gusto than that I
think yeah sure this was like a Wendy
Williams style death to all of them yeah
but it's not yeah it's not after doxing
a private citizen
yeah
make it a lot worse in my opinion yeah I
hear what you're saying yeah when I when
I make death threats I like to say it
with my whole body
let's get off that
so I guess that was it but then I guess
people started getting mad she didn't
cut it out yet that's interesting
oh people I mean all the comments are
that they loved her story
but what's been happening is
Babel
uh oh shout out Babel they also
I also bailed on me the last time I did
a death threat what do they have a
problem with death threats
[Laughter]
come on stop identifying clearly they do
yes wow prudes
yeah
during the episode sponsors uh Babel
Tana said and with Babel I could have
told Cynthia the wine tour Lady to shut
the up in her native way no way
it's edited out unfortunately that also
is something I have
basically done too during response that
is a wild
she added it that part out
Babel Has since said the company is no
longer working with Tana
and would have carefully vet podka more
podcast more in the future
we uh oh here it comes the statement
this absolutely does not align with
Babel's company's value
we only make death threats against
right right just don't right
horseberg wrote an email highlighted
here Tana is obviously not a person who
understands or celebrates the difference
in cultures and we regret to be in any
way involved with her oh that was the
problem she just wasn't she wasn't
celebrating French culture I thought it
was because of the death threat
um after the podcast episode was
released Cynthia told NBC news that she
had started receiving strange messages
from people on Instagram and her
business began receiving poor reviews
that sucks
the poor review thing
so lame bro that sucks for a business
owner
and she actually tried so hard to like
go out of the her way for her go I mean
traveling three ways both ways to Paris
to pick him up yeah after Cynthia
listened to podcast episode she said she
reported Tana's death threats
to the Paris Police
yeah similaries I was also reported to
the FBI
uh not parallels
like a butterfly's Wings what was that
video the guy who's he was he was
talking about me and he recorded himself
calling all right police yeah
oh my God his name is Ethan Klein oh
that's him I don't follow the guy okay l
e i n yeah he's on the Internet Straight
podcast with V8s okay you're like are
you currently under threat he's like
this happened seven days ago
I feel I feel understood about this yeah
good such a baby it's like bro you're
you have all these guns
um you're a baby yeah um we we have some
big news oh boy uh Tom the Tom Ward show
has become a member of the History
Podcast Channel
shot Tom you need that Fiverr bro don't
give it to us and I think he is
responding he is responding well
um let's get give him the link I mean
let's talk to him I can set up a
zoom yeah send him a zoom link okay one
second
he says you around let's do it
all right standby stand uh are you
sending it to him or where yeah I'll
send it from the podcast account
um he actually gave me my number so I'm
texting it to him okay perfect
damn you got Tom on speed though let's
go
did you send it not yet I was just
launching Zoom all right I'm gonna go
pee listen guys I've been going for like
over three hours I'm gonna pee thank you
then I'm gonna come back I'm gonna talk
to Tommy Boy and we're gonna figure all
this out careful for flushing so you
don't burn anything oh is it still
hot probably a little bit maybe
Sam did you did you turn it off or is it
still cooking in there
she's not here she's not here never mind
I doubt she left it on
just left them oh God
uh I was in there cleaning for a while
yeah yeah all right all right all right
I'll go to the bathroom when you think
it's back because
I don't want Tom calling me I'm not
gonna move for this right now I'm just a
big fan that's it I'm hiding yeah I'll
be making a steak in the bathroom
uh
uh there's a super chat a b that calls
you a b clout killer oh that's funny
yeah that's pretty funny I'm saying I'm
gonna change my name after this episode
to dream killer dream killer yeah it's
good
honestly it kind of what's this
uh thank you you're welcome Bobby
altoff just dropped receipts in the
Instagram story
proceeds for what
let's look into that let's wait for
Ethan if it's
something juicy I'm gonna go check it
out I'm on it yeah uh Dan is my favorite
member of the crew Ethan should be
thankful that Dan
what does it say The Dan created h3h3
and lets Ethan host the podcast yeah
well I know I just saw a lot of talent
in him decided to raise him up you know
uh
what else we got here I took an airplane
on Monday and listened to the podcast
for once and I gotta say audio version
of the audio version of the podcast
hitting program I enjoyed it a lot and
if you're an audio listener out there
you never see me and you never see what
I do for the show I'm sorry but I hope
you're still having a good time
still hear your beautiful voice
I'll be listening on Friday
oh Tom Ward has entered the waiting room
he's entered the waiting room he's here
people he's here
uh so that's exciting
Ethan will be back in a second a love
always has W takes me love that's uh
that's what um ear says I've always says
W takes for your information she was on
the nose she's on no sleep and hungover
later she was drinking blacking out on
tour and her fans have turned on here
right
that sucks
um Ethan Tom Ward has entered the
waiting room
let's come all right I also sent that
update for the uh
what's her name Bobby booby
all right I'm letting in what Bobby up
there waiting room talk to Tom first
[Music]
is that Tom Ward um can you mute the
stream please one second yeah no worries
he takes me hello that's uh that's what
um
wait Bobby's actually upset about this
this is fascinating let's do it after
right
Dom can you hear me that sucks
um Ethan Tom Ward has entered the
waiting room guys all right I also sent
that update what's happening Thomas
Tommy Boy
I don't know what all right I'm trying
to figure out what's going on
Tommy you live back there
Zach Tommy Boy his stream is still like
he has a stream open or something like
that yeah
my boy Tom Ward hold on hold on that's
what um
all right I'm muted is that okay yeah
there we go there it is Tom Ward
welcome to the show
hey girl first Tom thank you for calling
in I apologize you know for
we're being a little s uh
for sure hold on a second sorry gang am
I supposed to see you or no yes you
should be seeing me hold on I do not see
you yeah one second let me work that out
I see dance word love like nobody wants
to see that yeah nobody wants to see
that let's get that out of there hold on
there he is okay there you go okay so
what hey Tom thanks for being here God
bless you know uh we were a little
snarky so I apologize although we are
rooting for you Tom we are I appreciate
it
so um
what's going on what is your what is the
story here you're are you really looking
for a job at this point it's funny you
saw my tweet like legit
um
yeah like I'm not even pissed I watched
my wife's cousin text me and said uh
you know you were talking about me I'm
thinking like how am I even on his radar
like why you know what's he talking
about so I watched I lasted three
minutes yeah you know it was too tough
to watch me I couldn't you know I was so
bummed out and literally yeah like I was
looking for jobs this morning like I
have an interview tomorrow and I have
one Friday but like money's running out
YouTube ain't working like you're not
wrong like it's not working so it's like
it's time to figure this out and
yeah I was like I apologize for
that it's all right man but it is
fascinating because
there's something really I
like you have gotten consistently all
these famous people you've interviewed I
don't understand why the views are so
low I genuinely don't understand how can
you post an interview with Rob Dietrich
300 get 300 views yeah whatever that's
you're the interview I don't know I
don't know anyone's name that's your job
uh but how is it possible I don't
understand well that's the real reason I
reached out like it wasn't to like you
know be mad or like you know anything
like that I just wanted to be clear like
that there's no funny business going on
like behind the scenes oh yeah the part
I watch you're really speculating like
is he paying them are they paying him
for Forbes articles and all this stuff
um everything's really above board I
mean do you want to talk about how I
could guess sure I'd love to know yeah
so like the whole thing first of all
um I was an equipment I sold kitchen
equipment to grocery stores for the last
nine years like about as regular on show
busy job as you could possibly have
and I just hated my job so I start
blogging I read this book and about like
changing careers or finding out what you
really want to do I was just miserable
at work and one of the things was you
should blog because no one writes
anymore it'll set you apart like just
blog just right like no one writes
anymore so this is like six six years
ago so I start writing and no one's
reading no one gives a and then one
day Jessica Alba the actor somehow sees
my little blog post I was getting like
10 20 views a day like no one my mom and
like a couple friends maybe were reading
that's it somehow she sees an article I
wrote and posted on LinkedIn and it blew
up it got like 200 000 views in like 24
hours like to this day Jessica if you're
out there like I'm still my I have no
idea how she found it but anyway that
led me to an editor reaching out from
Forbes and saying like hey do you want
to be a contributor um I'm a sales guy
I'm not a professional writer I didn't
write for my school paper I'm just a
regular just a regular guy trying to
find out like a better job so I did it
and I was writing like clickbaity kind
of articles for Forbes like marketing
lessons you can learn from the
Kardashians was Forbes paying you for
that content they I mean they barely pay
I mean you have to jump through all
these groups that get paid so for me I
mean it's minimal I mean it's minimal
like it takes me a shitload of time to
write these the only reason that I did
it was for the you know the exposure it
gave me like
[Music]
so I'm just writing and then one day
um I get a pitch from this PR Guy saying
like hey do you want to interview this
kid Jake Paul
and I really they made yourself to you
well I interviewed Kate Hudson I got an
interview with Kate so how did you get
that interview I just reached out I just
I figured like I'm a sales guy I figured
Forbes like everyone would want to be in
Forbes like who wouldn't and like I
would pitch myself I was like Hey I want
to talk about business Kate like I'm not
interested in who you're dating or your
wedding or any of that like I
just I'm genuinely interested in like
fabletics like does it make money how do
you start like that's it okay so you
yeah so you're using the Forbes
Association saying no so she was the
first big famous person you got
for sure and there was no YouTube or
anything I just wanted to interview and
so were you Mass emailing or if you're
like PR person you could find like what
was the strategy back then
no it wasn't even really that well
thought out because again I had a
full-time job and I got two kids and I
got a wife and you know I got a like a
regular life I didn't have a shitload of
time but like I would religiously work
every Saturday and either write a Forbes
article because I didn't have time
during the week or I just reached out to
guests don't have like a nothing
scientific I had a Google spreadsheet
list okay so you were just reaching out
dream people and then were you reaching
out to their like PR team what where
were you contacting them
I didn't even know what a PR person was
I was just like randomly send them DMs I
would you know I would go on their
Instagram and sometimes they have an
email button I would just send an email
to wherever that goes okay so where did
the where did the message reach reach
Kate
which
I don't even remember but I don't even
remember but just the pr person reached
out to me okay okay
so they reached out and said yeah we'd
love to do this interview yeah
okay
and how'd it go
it was good I mean it was it was a lot
of work for like not that greater reward
like it was that you're watching this
and you've never been been to these
things like I hadn't you were just part
of oh you did the Press jumping
yeah yeah
I got you and I got like three questions
with her and then put me in front of the
CEO who I don't give a about but
they want the story about he wants to be
in four so you got to sit and listen to
him for 45 minutes so that was it
okay interesting well then I guess that
opened more uh potential for you to be
like hey I interviewed
these people and then the next the next
big one was Jake Paul
yeah it was so wild because I'm like
this is this is back in like 2015 2016.
I didn't know who Jake Paul was I didn't
know what a YouTuber was he sends me
this I was like 37 not 38 at the time so
he sends me this I'm like so I look him
up you know and I go who the is
this kid with like 20 million followers
I never even heard of like what's an
influencer because in 2015 it wasn't
like now where a Business Insider has a
whole team debate you know just creating
or covering content creators back then
there was only Taylor Lorenz was the
only person I know doing it
and I said that with Jake and like what
interested me most about Jake wasn't all
the Dr you know who he's dating or the
gossip I was a grown man like I didn't
care about that I was fascinated by like
the entrepreneurial side of them like
the marketing side like I sat down with
them for an hour and a half at the old
team 10 house which was a show just
showing up there and we just sat in his
garage for like an hour and a half and
chopped it up and he just talked about
business and the team that works for him
and I just I remember leaving there
being like everyone thinks this is some
dumb kid like I thought that an hour
before I walked in the house
but this is a smart dude running a
multi-million dollar business with like
a whole team of people working for the
organization like it's wild like do
people know this so so is that kind of
where you got interested in the
influencer side and then because I
noticed you started you interviewed like
Logan you interviewed Eric Chamberlain
so why is it then like it's it's such an
why is it do you think that it never
caught on I'm just I'm fascinated by
that
I think because
I didn't you know it's easy to get views
if you're gonna say like you sit down
with the song whoever the big influencer
is like who are you dating or like you
know talk about this person you're in a
beef with but like I was
you know that wasn't my thing like I'm
not a kind of gotcha controversial guy
like I was just genuinely interested in
the business behind them so yeah no one
was telling the story like like I said
Taylor was and that's it there was no
Business Insider there was no one
covering this stuff so like your theory
is that you were less focused on the
drama which would have got you more
engagement more focused on the business
side
correct yeah of course there's one with
Jason you're asking about Trisha and
stuff and actually you had this great
moment where he was defending Colleen
and uh it has four it has 400 views what
the Jason Nash I don't understand
how it's possible and I'm not saying
that to be mean I'm genuinely perplexed
like I'm I'm I feel like I'm on your
side and that I don't understand it
I give up man I don't get it I just know
it ain't working like yeah
yeah I don't know so you don't like me
they don't like the style interview I'm
not talking about the topics they want
who knows but I don't know let me see
you have oh they're probably just our
fans now we got to get you to the top
Tom yeah it's all just they're all nice
now
well that's nice thank you guys but um
so you have a you it seems like you
built out like a studio space you
invested a lot of time and money into
this
oh for sure ton of money how long have
you been doing it full time
just since last July like Dorne I know
that like you were talking about like
how how there's not much revenue coming
in like for before I quit my job which
was a mistake in hindsight like I was
probably spending I was a full-time so I
probably spent like 20 25 Grand a year
doing that yeah and which is insane like
I'm a regular guy but like I always
Justified it and my wife shout out to my
wife for letting me spend it was like
some guys like the golf some people have
a boat and they go out on the weekends
like I just wanted to talk to
interesting people and that's it like it
was just for the Love of the Game for me
I just was genuinely interested in doing
this talking to people that's it so did
you give yourself you're like all right
I'm gonna take a year off and see if I
can make something happen
yes I did I saved we saved money like
when I was doing influencers I was
getting you know little brand deals here
and there and I had a full-time job so I
just saved all that and then I was just
so miserable in my job I mean I'm
selling I'll never forget I'm on
conference calls about an oven I sold
um Sprouts Farmers Market like if you're
not near one it's the grocery store and
I'm on phone calls
conference goals for like five hours
about this one oven at this one store
that broke and then I leave
Paris Hilton's house to hang out and
interview for the for the day
and the whole thing is like and what
world does this even make sense like the
whole the whole thing was wild to
me and I under I mean listen it's good
you tried I think it's better to try and
see but how much cash have you burned
through in that year you don't have to
tell me if you're not comfortable I'm
just curious
uh like about what I would have made if
I stayed at my job for a year like a
year like a year's salary like real
money damn
yes
but but you know what though like
it like when I watch your video today I
watched the first five minutes at first
it hurt like if no one wants to be
called like a failure publicly basically
like I mean you said it you said like
hey man it ain't working like maybe it's
never gonna work and like you were right
like if I look at those five six years
it didn't work but for me like I'm
looking for jobs now and you feel like a
failure or not with other but
if I'm honest I got to do some cool
in the last year I would have never been
able to do it one guy at like 38 I mean
when you're 38 you're stuck in a career
you're kind of are where you are you may
hate your job maybe bounce around to
some companies and within the industry
and you retire that's it have
you thought about trying something new
it seems like you're specifically
focused on the interviewing have you
thought about maybe different strategies
to grow the channel or try to capture
new audience hey I'm gonna put ideas bro
I honestly don't have to figure it out
okay you want me to pitch some stuff I
can brainstorm for you
sure
um
probably I don't know if you're gonna
like this there's probably some kind of
bald fetish stuff on YouTube I swear to
God
let me type this bald fit now I don't
that's a pretty sharp left turn for your
channel granted but there is some yeah
there's views here there's views and in
the in the um chat they're really I hate
to say this uh they really need to calm
down but the the ladies and Chad are
simping for you hard
well I'm flattered I don't know why
happily married though right yeah
hey calm down in the chat I appreciate
it though it makes me feel good thank
you ladies
yeah um who was who is the most
interesting person you've
uh met and chatted with
regardless of Fame
Rob Dyrdek it probably affected my life
the most out of all the interviews I've
done he's just a wild guy like he if
you're watching this if you're
interested in like productivity and
stuff you watch it but he tracks every
second of his day
like literally like he'll track how much
and he's got he's got his life so dialed
in like that show Ridiculousness which
has been on forever makes a shitload of
money he's gotta like dialed in where I
think he he only spends like 20 hours a
week filming that right
and he's wild I've seen him talk yeah
I've seen him talking about like his
Venture Capital stuff he's really
focused
oh for sure he was telling me like after
interview he's like unless something
really up happens like I'll be a
billionaire
oh he's planning for it
oh for sure like he's got I mean tons of
businesses he's got his BC stuff like
he's dialed in but it wasn't always like
that like he pissed away his money you
know had bad people advising him like oh
I have to ask you you missed you
misspelled his name Tom do you think no
I saw that dude I saw that I mean after
after everything you did to put in and
and then maybe made I don't know you
didn't you gotta dot the eyes Tom I know
bro
well thank you for telling me Nation
whatever whatever this fan group is
called yeah you can call us the fuper
Troopers the family foot Army you could
call us so I changed it yeah good maybe
the views will go up now that it's
spelled right YouTube was confused
they're like who the is this
Rob dry deck
Dreer deck
all right well
um
Jason Nash it's kind of embarrassing for
him though that he didn't get more views
yeah it's not even your fault it's
Jason's fault at this point
you know if I you know I mean
if I came on your I can't do your show
Tom because I can't I'm too fragile I
can't go on your show and get 300 views
it would destroy me of course it's my
fault not your fault
totally understand
so Jason if you're watching what the
man
and Jason didn't share it anywhere
that's kind of did he not share it
anywhere he did he shared
no that is really sad that means like he
shared it and it only got 300 views what
is happening I was actually looking at
Jason Nash's Twitter and he has like a
couple tweets with like five likes on it
Jason yeah what the is going on Tom
that's nuts hard out there man
no kidding
now granted I haven't washed one of your
full uh interviews through so I I can't
I can't say anything about like the
approach or the quality or anything but
I mean man
it's popular his most popular one you
were at four years ago you had dubrick
dubrick's number one
uh with 830 000.
well I took a lot down I did because I
was I pivoted away from influencers so I
took a lot down but I interviewed Emma
Chamberlain when she first why would you
take that down because I wanted to move
away from influencers and kind of move
into more business stuff so that's also
part of the reason that why did you take
it down that doesn't make sense because
you still have dubarak Logan Paul and
all these other influences Charlie
demilio well they're unlisted I could
put them back up I mean if you guys
think I should put them up I'll put them
back up after those
yeah she's huge I mean that that's
a big deal to get Emma Chamberlain she's
really really big
oh for sure yeah I never had her on my
show Tom what the get it together
bro I mean if I can get them like you
have no excuse that's goddamn right
maybe you should be my Booker bro
you're like a beast Booker man you got
crazy guts
well I wouldn't explain and that's the
reason I reached out to I wanted to
explain because apparently I guess the
segment on me got better as time went on
but I didn't make it that long but the
one thing I didn't like
was kind of like the implication that
what's he doing is he selling Forbes
articles like how is he getting these
guests like do you mind me explaining
like how I do it sure go ahead
I mean there's no secret it's just that
pitch I sent you in 2019 that you shared
like yeah it's basically like hey I
wanna I'm interested in you one because
I have to write a Forbes article for you
so if I'm not interested
I don't want to do an article this is a
lot of work so like I'm genuinely
interested in you something sincere and
I said let's sit down and buy and
basically can we shoot it for YouTube
and most people say yeah the people that
have said no to that I still do the
Forbes article so it's not like I'm you
know holding them hostage but I also
provide clips about them talking about
business where a lot of these people
especially the creators don't have that
kind of content they want to show off
kind of like an entrepreneur so I
provide Clips to all the interviewers
said you don't have to show me in the
video if you don't want to like you
don't have to tag me like here's Clips
to do whatever you want and everyone
needs content
it's a good pitch I gotta say you know
like I said I almost agreed to it until
that that email you saw that email that
was pretty
did you write that Tom that email
I don't remember I didn't make it to
that part oh you didn't see it pull up
the email pull up the email actually me
and Dan my producer both remembered the
email because it was so funny
I don't know hold on let me pull it up
let me pull it up
oh
um
I I think it was a misunderstanding but
still it was it was quite funny me and
Dan both remembered it let me pull it up
here
I'm looking back
it's not blurred
oh
so does what's the name do you see it or
just send it to me
so did you ever pretend to be a PR
person
I had somebody help me before and
um no I had somebody help me I never
pretended I just I'm Tom you know oh so
no this is not the right one maybe
yeah
at times they hire people like uh you
know off upwork and stuff but they could
never so maybe it could come from them I
sent most of them though what's the
first name
because it's blocked out I can't see it
I
nobody can see it all right whatever
here I'll just pull it up oh it's
okay whatever so here is the email I got
and
it's it's it's funny don't worry
we're having a laugh so I got I said I'm
a talent Booker for the Tom Ward podcast
and I love to have Ethan on the show
I loved working with Timothy at full
screen I know what that means then she
said she says we can tape when and where
it's convenient for him
what that I would never say that
never I'm not the star I go where the
star wants to do it I'll do it at their
house I'll do it at their Studio I
thought that was so funny and then she
says we have a studio book this Thursday
so it's read to me like
I will only do this on my time Thursday
at the studio that's what it is and so I
responded wow he must be busy
yeah
no no look I'm the little guy I'm
humble like I would never send that I
did have someone helping me I won't name
her name
um and I tried a couple times to have
other people do that because it's a lot
of work yeah but they could never get it
they could never get the guess I could
get like I always had better luck than
they did and I don't know anyone at full
screen so yeah I don't know even if I
don't know what that is about but I I
always I cherish that email Tom and I
guess that's what even brought us back
to having this long discussion about you
I guess it worked out in a weird way
so um I'm an entrepreneur Tom okay
would you like to know anything about me
I would
what kind of Revenue do you I'm just
kidding I don't put you on the spot
would you what'd you make last year the
right question Tom nice try
no I don't want to say that how much did
you make last year
I just told you I lost
I didn't make any money yeah
I'll tell you uh him I don't know
it's time to level up
Martin you had Bradley Martin he's a
meathead isn't he
you know he was wild he cried during the
interview that was right the man cried
in the interview for sure he cried on
our show wait did but so you got tears
and did anyone watch it
no I don't think so Bradley Martin I
wouldn't do well on Tick Tock yeah have
you tried putting these on Tick Tock
because I I think Love's right about
that yeah they do way better on social
than they do on YouTube like the clips
like for I think Charlie demilio well I
interviewed her I don't know what I got
like 80 000 views or something the last
time which is like horrible but like the
clips I think five clips from it on Tick
Tock got like five million plus views so
okay they're no better on social they're
not converting
people to watching on YouTube although I
mean if things if things are popping on
Tick Tock it might be worth
pursuing that and focusing content for
that you know what I mean because a lot
of people have built really successful
careers on Tick Tock of all different
verticals did you take down the Bradley
Martin one I can't find it yeah I took a
bunch I'll tell you what uh I'll put
everything back up yeah dude come on
these are gems man nobody cares about
David dobrik
again
it's funny that I got pitched him today
I may do him next week again really nice
yeah he is wild like I'm telling you I
think it's a huge deal that's a huge cat
yeah it is David I mean he's about
as big as you guys don't mention
anything about eyeballs okay
sensitive topic soon yeah um so try to
think about how and he's huge on Tick
Tock too
you gotta work that man if you work that
right people are going to watch it
you know but like he's not going to talk
about Jeff and the eye anyone else would
ask about that
would get the most attention obviously
yeah but there's ways to let's see let's
see how can we approach it in a way
he'll talk about it but obviously not
explicitly about Jeff
um
he you could ask him about not posting
on YouTube anymore because that's
related to the drama he's just gone off
YouTube and that's real interesting you
know like he's gone he's just gone from
YouTube
killing it on Snapchat killing it and
then on Snapchat I know that there's a
special Creator uh program that pay I've
heard I'm not on Snapchat that pays like
insane I would definitely I just talked
to Jason I just talked to Jason about
this I won't say the number but they're
made but I mean they're making stupid
money but he was telling me they have to
post like a hundred times a day holy
I'm like how could you even I mean
what well he just he just records dumb
all day you know what I mean he's
just anything you just have it's called
numbers like the milk boys kill it on
there too I know their manager like
there's a lot of guys making a ton of
money on Snapchat not us not my dumb ass
I'm sure you're doing fine I tried they
didn't want me
didn't we reach out and they're like nah
didn't that happen uh
the conversation kind of fizzled fizzled
out yes oh yeah we were gonna make an
account Snapchat's annoying I don't want
to around with Snapchat I think
they did want you though
they did want me I believe so yeah
whatever
them right Tom
exactly
so I would ask about the Snapchat why is
he on Snap now we know the reason it's
because of the money you get you're
taking notes okay there we go see Tom
he's taking notes I'm on my Bro now
we know he's doing it because of the
money so it's interesting to ask him and
try to see like he's gonna spend some
silly narrative about like I just like
the way it's written just hear what he
says right
uh also again
not being on YouTube also being in you
could say you could kind of broadly be
like you've been through a lot of
controversies how has that affected how
does that affected your
your mentality oh another thing is
David's always been super controversy
adverse he's even said
that he would rather it's better to just
ignore everything never respond to
anything and so he was forced to respond
ultimately to a few things that happen
and I feel that that would be
interesting like what was different
about this one
that you wanted to respond to versus
like the Seth thing which you never
responded to those are pretty hard
hitting though I don't I don't know if
he's going to bail on those I don't know
as soon as you hear Jeff accident
controversy but even if he bails it's a
scoop bro oh for sure and that's
interesting stuff you know I don't know
but uh to be totally Frank with you he's
you're Pro I probably just ruined your
chance of Landing that interview
oh yeah yeah well like the only thing I
have on my side is I've interviewed him
twice and you have Rapport yeah I know
the guy I'm not gonna try to him
yeah yeah yeah maybe that's my problem
that is your problem hey for sure it's
not him it's just
[Music]
yeah
sorry I had to button that away Tom I
made a joke about it inappropriate Uncle
of David's a sphere fully speculative
yeah I don't I guess maybe I'm not the
best at giving advice on this sort of
thing
show me your notes is it empty show me
your empty Notepad
yeah you wrote some stuff okay smiley
face there you go
you know
thank you
you got any you you got any other ideas
other than the interviewing thing
I mean I'm not like a
super exciting guy like my life's pretty
boring
oh well I mean other than getting to sit
down with these people or go to events I
never go anywhere like so I'm not like a
vlog kind of guy like no one's
interested in that I mean maybe not a
vlog thing yeah
I mean so that's how have you tried like
going to celebrities houses and filming
they're inside their window without them
knowing
that because I never thought about that
that could be good
I know a Stars map guy will hook you up
maybe um
oh here's Bradley Martin let's see
yes Bradley Martin got thrown out of
before you open Zoo culture follow me
for more Clips like this originally I
was just gonna open a gym that I was
going to film my content out because I
kept getting I would I would just play
the clip especially yeah we tried that
doing the intro I don't do that anymore
you tried it okay okay
got thrown out of before you opened Zoo
culture yeah we just do this like this
originally I was just gonna open a gym
that I was gonna film my content out
because I can't keep talking about Dad
committed suicide like that was a pretty
wild story like you look at him like
some dumb Meathead and you're like oh
man yeah that obviously them
up yeah it is it is very touching that
whole
um all that he's been through definitely
lifting girls or doing crazy dumb
like just doing that like is not
normal for a gym yeah but I knew it was
working on the internet so I was like oh
I want to do more of this but then I
would go do it at like a Gold's Gym and
they would kick me out guess how many
gyms Bradley that's what you need to do
Tom you know what I mean go get kicked
out of places
dude yeah he goes it was work like the
things that are working for you seem to
be like Tick Tock let me check out your
tick tock
okay
let me see Tom Ward Tom Wards Tick Tock
is it words Tom Ward wrd
all right let's see so here's the Json
ones it's not really popping off let me
see this one got a thousand views let's
see void the negativity almost or
something it seems like whether it's
Trisha attacking you you're not
responding or with the Jeff stuff like
you mentioned before like hey I just saw
him at the gym yesterday you tried to go
there which I I like let's see where how
was it how do you stay I guess positive
and the music uh
yeah I don't like that either I don't
know why I put music in this one
I like it I think it's good but it's
making me feel like Jason's
Jason I'm inspired by how I think the
music is fine let's hear out of all the
trappings the drum that comes along with
it I learned like a long time ago that
like I can't win it that game so if you
feed into any of that I feel like this
was actually kind of interesting though
to be totally honest about the I can't
win that game
so for the people that like do drama
musical loud and you've got to be built
for that you've got to be able to be
like yeah I don't care and I don't
necessarily know if I'm built for that
how do you avoid it's not a bad clip
love you're the cliff guy what would you
do okay being super critical right yeah
loves our social media guy he's good I
would keep your question quicker and get
to him faster because if he's the famous
person so we want to see him faster I
guess less Tom sorry yes I just I I do
that with Ethan Newman when we talk
about the topic get to the topic
immediately you know yeah yes that's
true yeah
oh so we have a campaign going for Tom
to co-host of the Streamys
[Applause]
you say the streamies my man what's
your problem with the Streamys I hate
the Streamys too the whole thing seems
so ridiculous like who owns it I
remember I looked into it once
who are they like I remember
like I should cover this I interview all
the big influencers like they're all
going to be there and they never got
back to here they did something pissed
me off like them there's
uh we're going to the stream is this
year we're trying to win
we're trying we're playing ball this
year
can I talk about that Dan
yeah you can talk about it I don't think
we have said it though yes so these guys
have been peer pressuring me so bad the
crew Ila they've been on me I go I do
not want to go to the Streamys last year
they announced the freaking category
during the commercial break
you know because we weren't there and so
well we said okay I still told Streamys
everyone on the crew is coming
and we get our own table at the front
and they said yes to that
okay
they asked me to present I said I'm not
presenting
I'm not doing that
then we said
tell us is this going to be a stage
category or a commercial category
they seem to apply to us right
potentially
that it won't be a commercial category
because we'll be there that's what I'm
saying that it makes sense right they
said last year nobody showed up from the
podcast bracket right so of course they
announced it and so
but the thing is I'm up against Shetty
and I know shetty's gonna he's gonna win
Creator he's gonna sweep the whole fight
do you know who Jay Shetty is Tom
yeah you know what's so funny I was I
wanted to interview him and I actually I
shot up a DM on Instagram I don't know
like six months ago or something and
then I looked he messaged me in like 26.
hey I really like the art the article
you did about Lele pons like would you
want to have me on and I said no
I said I said
yeah
creators dude you said no to the
such a dumbass it's such I was
like kicking myself you said no bro rude
I said No at the time did you even have
a following at the time
not really I just wasn't interested in
Jason yellow
that's the best I didn't know who he was
like opportunity comes knocking at your
door and you're like no
I like Hello opportunity shut the door
in the face
so dumb so awesome so if we are we are
revealing a little bit about your
journey you just you'd like to shut
opportunity is is uh
isolated incident
what this is an isolated incident uh-huh
there's a lot of isolated incidents Tom
I don't know what that means sorry
so but he's like the biggest now uh Jay
Shetty he's interviewing Biden he's a
piece of
the only reason he's successful is
because he has beautiful eyes what band
Tom you got to understand he's like
Enemy Number One to Ethan
oh wow
kind of semi-oronic but also because he
because he always wins the streamies
he's beating him
damn time and I'll tell you what his
program is not that good Tom you should
be more Jay Shetty is and Jay Shetty
should be out just being I don't
know he has beautiful eyes go do
something with that get off my
if you look like he's kind of secure and
I follow him like he's doing more
influencers now which is smart if I want
to win stream he's year after year I
sprinkle in I do the president throw in
some big influencers over here do you
think he's award-baiting
possibly yeah I think so too you know he
probably aren't even on the board of the
stream he's who knows man you're crazy
yeah um
did you ever reach back out to sheddy
and be like Psy come on the show please
oh yeah like
when I when I saw like we shot a year
ago and I saw that I go it let me
just ask him anyway who cares you know
he goes to you right yeah and he got a
big time deal he's like I remember this
guy yo there's an interesting
idea theory in the chat that um uh
that's that Jay Shetty got you
blacklisted
because you said no to him yeah yo
because how else would your interviews
get so little views Shetty has that
power
and he is mean-spirited I know that
Shady I'm sure is a good guy he has way
too much time to worry about me
he holds a grudge I know that about him
he thinks about you regularly the guy
who said no it's rubbed him wrong all
these years
he cursed you
maybe did man
you Jay you're there now we're
talking Jay Shetty Tom Ward all day
damn now I like the Tom Ward show this
is a show
let's see Jay Shetty is nominated first
of all in the podcast category
of course uh with me US Jay shetty's
also creator of the year like can we
please let someone else like Logan Paul
finally get his chance
he doesn't really fit in that list I
mean who sticks out to you I mean he
sticks out to me he's not like he's more
like a 60 Minutes correspondent or
something at this point yeah honestly
this is why
this is just not for me I don't know why
you guys are making me go to this
I don't know everybody on here it'd be
fun dude we're gonna get all glammed up
but like Charlie demilio J Shetty Logan
Paul what year is it
like this what the I got Mr Beast
on there he'll probably win I mean he
should win frankly because uh he's Mr
Beast I mean what the Charlie
demilio no offense to the emilios but
2023 you know let's move on Chevy has
way nicer eyes than Mr abuse though let
me see your eyes we'll color your eyes
tell me are those lights alive Brown
Hazel yeah yeah
oh my boy beautiful Hazels thank you you
got them you gotta work those for what
they're worth man do you consider doing
some kind of eye lighting so that they
Shimmer more in the interviews does the
bald fetish does it help if you have
nice eyes I think it all works it all
works
it all works it's very good how tall are
you six foot let's go you got it all man
[Applause]
how old are your kids
um eight and four beautiful yeah two
girls two girls I have two boys four and
one and a half oh nice okay I remember
those beautiful right
beautiful the best oh no Horrible no I
mean they're tough years four in one
yeah they're they're a handful man and
the two boys together it's like that I
think it's like the Tasmanian devil you
remember that character they're both
Tasmanian devils just swirling chaos
all the time
poor is a cute age one's tough
4-H one is Yeah well yeah they need a
lot of they need help with everything
like come on dude grow up already stop
being so worthless
my four-year-old does for me now
I'd be like yo can you take this to the
trash can you get me that and he does
for me I was like yo this is paying
off that's sick
this investment is starting to have
dividends
you know I only dream of the day I can
ask him to pick up the dog like my
I used to have to do
right
all right listen Tom I've been going way
over
uh it's been a pleasure to talk to you
I don't know what but something's got to
be done Tom I mean it's just not right
it ain't working so I have accepted that
mix it up bro listen to me if you get
that dobric interview this is your last
shot bro this is it get in there and
mix it up man
because what what are you gonna go do
another vanilla interview for what
purpose you're gonna go get a
another job yeah you gotta you gotta mix
it up bro get in there make some
happen you're right it's your last shot
absolutely right
so change up your technology
[Applause]
but I'm saying don't go in there and do
another vanilla interview you gotta mix
it up
try to get some more interviews and just
get in there and turn it all
upside down you're not Tom Ward anymore
you're not dried what's your name
backwards pick up David's chair with
like an excavator or something
mid-interview
that'll get some attention on you that's
it I'm saying just go you know do crazy
well how about this could I tell
you where the interview is and you both
those the
with an excavator you just interrupt the
interview that'd be that would be
fantastic potentially highly illegal
are you is it can we destroy your studio
is that okay can we just demolish it I
mean this is my office this is no studio
so can we destroy your home
sure okay sure that'll work
my man is committed
oh but one thing before we go though I
did want to say one thing like when you
we talked about it before about you know
is he using the Forbes thing and all
this other stuff like the one thing
is I don't for some reason like there's
thousands of contributors Forbes and
entrepreneur and ink magazine and all
these other places right and they could
do the same exact thing I'm doing yeah
but yeah maybe they are I don't know but
for some reason the guests come to me
and I honestly I'm shocked Like My Views
are so horrible that I'm surprised
I'm interviewing corporate Natalie
tomorrow I don't have to do a Forbes
article I'm interviewing Pat bed David
who's like a crazy business guy on
social media doing him Friday no forms
corporate Natalie looking that up so
she's a big she's a work she's a
I don't know what she does she's like a
millennial had a corporate job during
the pandemic started making content and
then what's the other person you said
at bet David it's kind of a weird name
Patrick you do you have this uncanny
ability to get people on your show
there's something there's something
going on Tom that we need to figure out
that's what I'm saying like these people
despite my views being awful my
channel being dead you know all this
other that you clearly you know
talked about and laid it out for me this
morning
um they keep coming on wait and I don't
know why like I've been here
interviewing this guy's a big deal
you're interviewing him that's what I'm
telling you and I don't have to do it
for he's just coming on the Tom Ward
show that is huge for you yeah so mate
you got it dude so let's go go in with
this whatever I've been doing it doesn't
work for sure nobody's watching so the
problem is not the guess clearly or the
platform you've got the formula the
problem is somehow however you're
approaching these interviews
go in there and mix it the up dude
go into Goblin mode that's what they
call it in the that's what the kids call
it
you know okay get nervous get in there
feel anxious get nervous put yourself
outside your comfort zone
and this guy's got there's a lot of
juice about this guy man you could do a
real good interview with him it's
interesting guy
oh for sure I haven't prepped for him
yet but yeah I'll do that tomorrow after
I'm done with Natalie so um that's
really exciting I mean do you have a lot
of really good opportunities coming up
that's exciting
I mean we're all gonna be watching I'd
love to see what you make with these I
appreciate man thanks for having me on
to kind of defend myself a little bit
and uh you don't need to defend yourself
Tommy it was nice from where I was two
hours ago so I appreciate it well if you
just so you know if you watch the um
the rest we got less mean and more
supportive people wanted me to tell you
that by the end we loved yeah you might
want to if you watch the whole thing
you'll feel better I think all right
thank you but I I'm excited for you I
think you can do this with these you
have this you have these big
opportunities coming up we're all going
to be watching
okay
well thank you guys thanks for watching
Nick Brad Miller man I appreciate it all
right mix it up Tom remember
Goblin mode Tom get the in there
all right buddy nice chatting all right
guys thanks guys talk to you I'll talk
to you soon we'll stay in touch all
right bye Tom
work goodbye dude big interview is
coming up yeah dude like you could
definitely do something interesting with
this dude
well especially for his Niche I think
that is a huge opportunity because that
guy's podcast is very business focused
and everything and so the the crossover
potential the angle that he wants to
approach it from of talking to you know
influencers and famous people about
their entrepreneurship
um is more valuable through that goal
but it's not a good angle don't
encourage him dude I don't know it is
they're very successful podcasts but if
not but how but it's not happening every
true but everything's got to do
something different when we ask people
on the show how much money they make
Tick Tock Revenue everything I make a
clip of that three million views okay
but why I think he's got to loosen up
because he's like
because he goes oh Jay shetty's not in
my bucket so no you gotta loosen up you
gotta not you can't just talk about this
one thing
but also this guy has like a lot of
questionable tags a lot of questionable
opinions he's very political he's had a
lot of questionable people on his
podcast you know I don't know Tom's
politics or if he's uncomfortable doing
that but in my opinion my point is just
this
he's got yeah
controversy a little bit more that that
I that I I'm not even saying controversy
necessarily just something different
yeah if he goes into this interview and
just goes in vanilla let's talk about
business nobody's gonna watch it again
fair enough
shetty's got him cursed or some I
think
at least we got him to say Jay that
was good that was very funny
the fact that he Big Time Jay's sheddy
that was dude so icon that's gold so
iconic let's go baby all right we are at
four hours and 10 minutes oh what quick
uh react to this for love
thanks so this is really
interesting so Bobby just posted this
update about the Drake thing she said I
did not want to do this podcast in the
first place and now so much negativity
is coming from it I'm going to leave it
alone after this but this is the
uncensored DM between David you're
talking about doing days he's talking
about Dave who is a giant piece of
which we all know okay so she
didn't go on it and now he's causing all
this trouble for her so here's their
whole conversation my girlfriend says
you hooked up with Drake and got
divorced I'm saying that is not true
she said I am not commenting publicly
but off the Record you're right that is
not true
I knew I was right then he goes on his
show and says and bleeps it oh believe
right he bleeped it so it sounded like
he was saying something compromising
right he's all up that's what I'm
saying it's up isn't that
literally the definition of uh what's it
called the legal statue where you say
something it's not true defamation right
um you knowing it's not true because he
didn't say it oh yeah okay he's fine but
like the obvious implication of it is
super up super super up
and Bobby again I'm on your side girl
Bob Dave pork boy he's a piece of
he's an I've known this from the
beginning come talk to me
off the Record DM me you can tell me
anything you want I won't share it on
the show I promise
never have never will on the Tom Ward
podcast Bobby yes
all right so there it is Bobby I'm sorry
you have to deal with Dave that was
really messed up what he did yeah cool
not cool Dave
um so she dispelled the rumor though so
there it is anyway shout out to Tom Ward
uh thank you everyone for watching this
has gone way over yep way over how long
we've been going Ethan is giving bad
advice how the am I giving bad
advice don't read the chat the worst
advice you could give this poor guy he's
put his life on pause he's put it all on
the line is to go in there and then do
another goddamn interview the same way
he's been doing it yeah no absolutely
do you know gamoch he doesn't need
another Yes Man like or like gamoosh or
like what do they call his uh the douche
toxic positivity well right
yeah yeah what do you know about it
Ethan what do you do for a living
nothing I don't know nothing about it
gamoch knows where's your show gamut
I think it's good advice and anyway he
doesn't have to take it it's got nothing
to lose
thank you guys for watching thank you to
Tom thank you to Samantha
bro the beautiful three-quarters meal
well done Samantha how long we've been
going Dan this is a month four hours and
10 minutes what the all right I
gotta get out of here we gotta go thank
you guys be back tomorrow morning with
leftovers be back on Friday after dark
you know what it is it's the H3 podcast
we're here all the time
see you next time
[Music]